bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre cet après-midi
en séance l'examen par les sénateurs du
projet de loi déjà adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale qui doit permettre
la création de la BPI la banque publique
d'investissement je vous rappelle qu'il
s'agissait du premier des 60 engagements
de campagne de François Hollande et
c'est un des éléments clés comme l'a
souligné le rapporteur socialiste ici au
Sénat François Marc un des éléments clés
donc du Pacte National pour la
croissance la compétitivité et l'emploi
adopté en novembre par le gouvernement
alors la BPI doit fusionner certaines
structures déjà existantes comme ozo ou
encore le FSI le fond Stratégique
d'Investissement objectif financer les
PME les petites et moyennes entreprises
qui sont porteuse de projets d'avenir
mais les sénateurs vont veiller à ce que
les régions qui sont des acteurs
économiques important en ce qui concerne
le développement local et bien de ces
entreprises soi associé à ce projet de
loi tout de suite donc direction
l'émicycle pour suivre cette séance bon
après-midi à
tous messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relative à la
création de la banque publique
d'investissement et de la proposition de
loi organique adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée relative à la
nomination des dirigeants de BPI group
il a été décidé que ces deux textes
feraient l'objet d'une discussion
générale commune dans la discussion
générale commune la parole est à
Monsieur Pierre Moscovici ministre de
l'économie et des finances vous avez la
parole monsieur le
ministre
va monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs le projet de loi portant
création de la Banque publique
d'investissement je vais l'appeler PPI
dans la suite de mon intervention
matérialise le premier des 60
engagements du Président de la
République c'est un des éléments majeurs
de notre dispositif de reconquête de la
compétitivité française
pour résumer j'ai coutume de dire et je
le dis devant vous que la BPI est pour
moi le porteavion du pacte de
compétitivité adopté par le gouvernement
ce projet de loi si vous l'adoptez
donnera vie un outil de croissance
offensif au service de l'économie réelle
au service des TPE au service des PME au
service des PME industriels au service
des établissement de taille
intermédiaire qui veulent se développer
sa vocation première sera en effet
d'apporter un un soutien aux entreprises
is qui ont un projet de croissance en
agissant comme un levier pour les
financements privés la BPI sera une
autre
banque j'oseraiis presque dire une
certaine idée de la
banque c'est ce que j'ai dit lors de la
discussion à l'Assemblée nationale pour
définir les contours et les missions de
la BPI nous nous sommes appuyés sur un
diagnostic lucide des faiblesses
actuelles du financement de notre tissu
productif ces faiblesses elles sont
d'abord financières en France les TPE
les PME les ETI
se finance difficilement à court terme
et elles anticipent un accès au
financement au crédit bancaire pour le
financement de long terme qui soit plus
difficile deux failles de marché qui
aujourd'hui sont
béantes la trésorerie alors que les
délais de paiement s'allongent et le
crédit d'investissement de moyen terme
quant à l'accès au fonds propres il
demeure vous le savez contraint
notamment pour le développement et pour
l'innovation depuis plusieurs années le
capital investissement recule en France
par ailleurs nous manquons d'inrum
efficac de financement à l'export qui
soit compétitif au regard de ceux de nos
voisins ces faiblesses elles sont
financières mais elles sont aussi
d'ordre institutionnel sur le terrain
reconnaissons-le vous le savez mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs il y a peu de
chefs d'entreprise qui arrive à se
retrouver aisément dans le Maqui des
dispositifs qui n'ira qu'il y a
complexité qui n'ira que face à tant de
complexité une réforme de simplification
de rationalisation de mise en cohérence
était et est nécessaire ces faiblesses
elles sont également stratégiques
l'éparpillement des dispositifs actuels
euh hypothèque la mobilisation des
financements en soutien aux filières
d'avenir ou filières stratégique je ne
suis pas le partisan de construction
institutionnelle pour le plaisir de la
mécanique elle-même mais aujourd'hui
reconnaissons que les pouvoirs publics
ne sont pas capable d'articuler
correctement leur action de financement
des entreprises et d'investissement dans
dans certains secteurs il faut
rapprocher les outils de financement et
de prise de participation les mettre
sous un pilotage unique tout en prenant
toutes les mesures nécessaire pour
éviter les conflits d'intérêts et ce
projet de loi vise à cela même rétablir
un pilotage efficace de l'état de
l'ensemble des instruments de
financement au service d'une stratégie
commune mise en œuvre par un même
opérateur la banque publique
d'investissement les faiblesses elles
sont enfin opérationnelles et
coule de tout ce qui vient d'être dit
dès lors qu'il y a faiblesse financière
dès lors qu'il y a faiblesse
institutionnelle dès lors qu'il y a
faiblesse stratégique il est logique que
le modus opérandi sur le terrain du
financement des entreprises soit d'une
complexité exagéré la BPI et bien elle
vise à répondre à toutes ces faiblesses
elle apportera une réponse précise et
exigeante à chacune de ces défaillances
concrètement le projet de loi que vous
examinez cet après-midi rend rempli de
trois objectifs d'abord créer
juridiquement la banque publique
d'investissement ensuite préciser ses
missions enfin déterminer ses modalités
de gouvernance tant au niveau national
qu'au niveau régional vous savez
néanmoins je veux y insister d'emblé que
donner vie donné cher à la BPI c'est un
effort qui va dépasser le texte de loi
le texte de loi était nécessaire mais
derrière la loi il y aura une
construction financière complexe à
mettre en place les opérations de nature
capitalistique ou d'organisation sont
menées en parallèle pour permettre de
rendre la BPI opérationnelle le plus
rapidement possible dès début 2013 il y
a une attente vous le mesurez tous dans
vos régions des équipes sont déjà au
travail sous la responsabilité d'un
préfigurateur Monsieur Nicolas dUFC et
je souhaite que le premier conseil
d'administration de la BPI se réunissent
en janvier et je l'ai dit autant que
faire se peut en région car cette banque
publique d'investissement je vais y
revenir n'est pas une banque comme les
autres n'est pas une banque elle est
publique maiselle ne doit pas être
centralisé c'est la banque des
territoires alors répondons aux
différentes questions d'abord à quoi
servira la BPI je vais vous donner une
définition extrêmement simple large
peut-être mais aussi ambitieuse et
précise la BPI c'est la banque de la
croissance française ce n'est pas une
banque comme les autres c'est d'abord la
banque des entreprises c'est la banque
je l'ai dit des TPE des PME PMI des ETI
de croissance qui doit leur permettre de
financer leur essort de croître
d'exporter la BPI ce sera un instrument
financier global au sens où elle offrira
distribuera l'ensemble des outils de
soutien financier de conseil et
d'accompagnement accompagnement
j'insiste sur ce dernier point
nécessaire au développement des
entreprises donc on y trouvera des prêts
évidemment des garanties le financement
de l'innovation le financement de
l'internationalisation des entreprises
tout ça étant aujourd'hui éclaté entre
Oso le fond Stratégique d'Investissement
le FSI région CDC entreprise et à terme
ubiifrance et la
cofas dire cela c'est aussi rendre
hommage à ce qui existe déjà c'est en
souligner l'insuffisance ou plutôt les
progrès qu'il convient d'effectuer par
le rassemblement de toutes les forces
mais c'est dans ce sens-là que nous
devons aller voilà pour les actions et
c'està dire que la BPI et je peux
entendre sinon cette critique du moins
cette interrogation fera la même chose
que les instruments actuels elle fera
mieux elle fera aussi plus et elle
rendra de nouveaux services aux
entreprises la BPI sera l'outil
financier des politiques nouvelles que
nous initions notamment dans le cadre du
pacte de compétitivité je rappelle
qu'elle aura et c'est une augmentation
très substantielle plus de 40 milliards
d'euros de capacité d'intervention
financière et si si on fait levier sur
le secteur privé puisque le principe de
fonctionnement ce sera le cofinancement
ça fait plus de 70 milliards d'euros on
ne peut pas tout attendre de la BPI
j'entends les attentes qui se font jour
dans nos régions je les écoute et je
pense qu'on aura un outil extrêmement
important parfois j'ai le sentiment
qu'on surestime aussi ce qu'elle peut
faire elle ne sera pas la baguette
magique du financement de l'économie
mais elle sera un levier nouveau et un
levier considérable pour le financement
de l'économie quelques exemples d'abord
la BPI ne sera pas un guichet passif le
guichet unique je veux y insister ce
n'est pas le guichet derrière lequel on
fait la queue pour remplir des
formulaires la BPI va accompagner
individuellement 1000 PME eteti à
l'export et ensuite elle développera de
nouveaux services en application du PACT
de compétitivité je pense au dispositif
de trésorerie que nous mettrons en place
au 1er janvier 500 millions d'euros de
crédit de trésorerie pour les PME je
pense aussi au préfinancement du crédit
d' impôt recherche ainsi qu'au
préfinancement du crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité l'emploi que vous serez
amené à voter bientôt je tiens
d'ailleurs être clair sur ce point la
BPI mettra en place un préfinancement du
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi mais
pas pour les grandes entreprises pas
pour celles qui pourront faire valoir le
créance auprès du réseau bancaire mais
le plus possible vers les PME ça ne veut
pas dire que la BPI sera un instrument
de débudgétisation pour consentir à ce
préfinancement elle mettra en place un
dispositif de garantie qui permettra de
mobiliser le secteur bancaire sur des
segments de marché sur lesquels celui-ci
n'irait pas spontanément la BPI ce sera
aussi la banque du tissu économique de
nos territoires
compagnera au plus près du terrain
celles et ceux qui hors des grands
groupes sont porteurs de projets de
développement d'expansion d'innovation
mais qui peinent et on le sait ils sont
nombreux à trouver des financements sur
les marchés la structure même de la BPI
reflète ce souci de servir les
l'économie réelle et les entreprises de
croissance Banque nationale car CEN est
une la BPI offrira et distribuera ces
outils via un réseau unique de direction
régionale au plus près des territoires
une banque nationale 22 directions
métropolitaines des directions dans les
territoires d'outrem voilà ce qu'est la
BPI la structuration de ce réseau qui
pour avoir des déclinaisons différent
selon ce que souhaiteront les
collectivités régionales j'y insiste
sera d'ailleurs et est d'ailleurs une
des premières missions de Nicolas duf
ici au Sénat je veux rappeler
l'engagement pris par le Président de la
République avec et en direction des
présidents de région la BPI c'est
l'occasion de mutualiser les
interventions d'accueillir ensemble les
entreprises entre l'État et les régions
ce projet en vérité témoigne de notre
volonté de mettre toutes les
collectivités publiques au service du
redressement productif redressement
productif ça signifie que la BPI est
aussi la banque de la stratégie
industrielle de ce gouvernement Banque
Nationale banque publique la BPI offrira
une logique obéira une logique propre sa
structure permettra de développer le
soutien financier aux filières
stratégiques pour l'économie non
seulement de telle ou telle entreprise
mais du pays le PACT de compétitivité
vous le savez en a dénombré 5 et ces
ressources seront à cet égard confiées à
la BPI au titre du programme des
investissements d'avenir 2 milliards
d'euros pour investir dans les
industries les filières stratégiques de
la France enfin la BPI est sera un
instrument au service de l'avenir et de
la croissance je veux le dire avec la
fermeté d'un élu je salue monsieur le
rapporteur d'une région qui connaît une
profonde et douloureuse mutation
industrielle la BPI c'est un moteur
c'est pas une roue de secours ser
d'ailleurs contraire au droit européen
une phrase de Taleran ça arrive que
j'aime bien il n'y a plus de sauveur de
la patrie ils ont gâché le métier encore
une fois N considérons pas là que c'est
la baguette magique ne donnons pas
nous-même l'impression que la BPI va
sauver toutes les entreprises de France
ce n'est pas ce rôle ça ne veut pas dire
que nous ne devons pas traiter et bien
traiter le cas des entreprises en
difficulté mais il y a d'autres outils
il y a d'autres interlocuteurs qui
existent pour répondre à ces défis il y
a des politiques nationales tout d'abord
pour prévenir les difficultés c'est pour
aider la trésorerie des entreprise que
par exemple j'ai lancé un plan pour
lutter contre les délais de paiement des
délais de paiement plus court ce sont
des manques de trésorerie en moins ce
sont souvent des faillites évitées il y
a des outils de prévention ensuite je
proposerai dans quelques jours la
nomination d'un nouveau Médiateur du
crédit arnaau Montebourg vous le savez a
aussi mis en place les commissaires au
redressement productif dans toutes les
régions de France qui sont les
interlocuteurs des entreprises qui
connaissent des difficultés il y a enfin
les politiques de soutien et
d'accompagnement des entreprises qui
vont mal pour préserver l'emploi c'est
pour aider ces entreprises en que
Christian tobira a lancé la réforme de
la justice commerciale dans le cadre du
PACT de compétitivité alors je le dis
ici nous n posons pas les belles
entreprises entre guillemets auxquelles
la BPI serait consacrée et les autres il
n'est pas question de laisser de côté
les entreprises qui souffre mais il est
indispensable et c'est le métier de la
BPI je le dis sans ambiguïé
d'accompagner d'aider le développement
la montée en gamme de nos entreprises
monté en gamme ce mot est au cœur du
rapport Gallois tout le monde a retenu
une idée qui est la baisse du coût du
travail mais c'est loin d'être la seule
la baisse du coût du travail comme le
reste du PACT sont faits pour permettre
à notre industrie de relever la tête
pour lui permettre de monter en gamme
pour lui permettre d'être compétitive
c'est-à-dire d'affronter en vérité la
compétition internationale celle des
entreprises industrielles des autres
pays européens des autres pays du monde
je pense à l'Allemagne d'abord notre ami
voisin et concurrent voilà ce qu'il faut
faire et la BPI c'est son rôle c'est sa
vocation permettre que ces entreprises
les industries françaises puissent être
performante innovante conquérante c'est
là son ambition un mot à présent sur la
structure et sur la gouvernance de la
BPI je dirais je l'avoue je le dis ici
je suis devant une assemblée qui est une
assemblée hautement politique la BPI
c'est un projet politique je passe
rapidement sur la structure tout d'abord
parce que vous la connaissez disons que
la BPI sera constituée d'une structure
de tête dont l'État et la Caisse des
Dépôts et Consignation seront
actionnaires à parité nous y avons tenu
deux filiales spécialisées dédié à ses
principaux métiers deux au départ une
pour le financement et une pour
l'investissement je ne reviens pas sur
les débats suscités par la presse
spécialisée le gouvernement depuis le
départ pour ce qui le concerne a
présenté un projet clair un projet qui
n'a pas changé un projet qui crée un
groupe public intégré et qui assure la
séparation des activités pour plus de
sécurité la structure de tête elle aura
la charge de définir la stratégie
d'ensemble du groupe d'assurer le
pilotage de son réseau régional du
contrôle des risques et d'affecter les
ressources du groupe selon ses priorités
ensuite en de ça en quelque sorte une
gouvernance
opérationnel intégré associant
l'ensemble des forces vives du pays
caractérisera la BP car je le répète ça
aussi ça montre que ce n'est pas une
banque comme les autres elle reposera
sur un conseil d'administration exécutif
de 15 membres présidé par un président
non exécutif du groupe où ces
actionnaires auront la majorité
disons-le c'est le directeur général de
la Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation qui
a vocation à présider ce conseil
d'administration elle sera dirigée sur
le plan opérationnel par un directeur
général exécutif
qui présidera également car il faut
qu'il a un vrai leadership une vraie
autorité les conseils d'administration
de ces différentes filiales sa
nomination sera soumise à l'avis des
commissions des finances des deux
chambres surtout nous voulons une BPI
qui laisse toute sa place au collectif
et donc sa gouvernance associera
l'ensemble des forces vives du pays
partenaires sociaux représentant des
salariés des entreprises des secteurs
d'intervention prioritaire de la BPI
tout cela
sera associé à cette gouvernance et ces
parties prenantes siégeront à son comité
national d'orientation qui participera à
l'élaboration de la stratégie et qui je
vais revenir un peu ultérieurement sera
présidé par un président de région le
président de la RF pour ne rien cacher à
vocation à présider ce comité national
d'orientation bref ce que nous proposons
c'est une institution financière
exemplaire encore une fois une banque
pas comme les autres j'insiste sur ce
point-là car il est crucial pour moi la
structure que nous proposons enrichie
par les travaux des députés enrichie
maintenant bientôt par les vôtres elle
est exemplaire elle est exemplaire dans
ces activités il n'y aura pas d'activité
de compte propre au sein de la BPI pas
non plus d'activités spéculative
uniquement des activités pour le compte
de ses clients je reviendrai devant vous
bientôt pour présenter la réforme
bancaire qui vise à remettre la finance
au service de l'économie réelle mais là
nous avons un outil qui est d'emblé est
au service de l'économie réelle elle
sera exemplaire dans son organisation
aucun conflit d'intérêts n'entachera la
BP c'est pour cela que nous séparons les
activités de crédit les activités
d'investissement c'est pour cela que les
élus participent à des organes
d'orientation d'activité de la BPI mais
pas au comité d'investissement qui
prendront les décisions financières
individuelles ça a été l'objet de débat
à l'Assemblée nationale je pense que
c'est une position sage et je vous
demande là aussi de la partager moi je
trouve tout à fait normal que les élus
soient là dans une banque qui est la
banque des territoires et en même temps
il faut protéger euh et faire en sorte
que les choses soient claires euh c'est
pour cela enfin que l'Autorité de
contrôle prudentiel assurera une stricte
surveillance les discussions à
l'Assemblée nationale et au sein de la
commission des finances de la Haute
Assemblée ont contribué à rendre cet
outil plus exemplaire encore euh je
dirais voilà ces discussions permis
d'enrichir le texte pour faire de la BPI
le POR étendard de plusieurs des
principes clairement posés par le
gouvernement la parité la parité il
faudra que dans les organes de
gouvernance la parité soit respectée
tout de suite la transparence totale la
modération sur les rémunérations c'est
une banque publique elle doit être dans
le champ des limitations qui ont été
mises en place mis en œuvre par ce
gouvernement le contrôle accru du
Parlement la garantie que le législateur
pourra contrôler toute ouverture du
capital de la BP son là des apports
majeur je veux saluer le travail
constructif exigeant de nos
parlementaires je suis évidemment prêt à
poursuivre cela avec vous maintenant et
vous pouvez vous pourrez je le crois
être fier mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de donner naissance par votre
vote à cette institution financière que
je crois novatrice et je le redis
exemplaire dans sa gouvernance et puis
enfin je veux faire de le BPI un
instrument puissamment ancré dans les
territoires qui a la vocation à
développé pour la première fois nous
créons une entreprise publique pour
porter l'action conjointe de l'État et
des collectivités conformément aux
engagements pris par le Président de la
République la banque plus
d'investissement est fondée sur un
partenariat entre l'État et les régions
qui pourront mettre leurs moyens en
commun au service du financement des
entreprises en témoigne la proposition
que j'ai pu faire aux régions dans le
projet de loi de participer directement
à la gouvernance opérationnelle de la
BPI j'ai parlé du Comité National don
orientation donc c'est le président de
la RF al la Rousa qui a vocation à le
faire je je suis heureux de dire que
nous avons pu poser avec lui des
discussions ont eu lieu les bases d'une
gouvernance équilibrée et partagée deux
représentants des régions siégeront en
outre à son conseil d'administration
cette fois-ci et là encore c'est un
accord qui a été trouvé avec la RF qui
convient paritairement bien évidemment
plus directement sur le terrain les
présidents de région présideront le
comité Ré Gal d'orientation un élément
important du dispositif malheureusement
oublié dans le texte issu de l'Assemblée
heureusement d'ors et déjà été rétabli
par votre commission des finances nous
devons profiter de nos discussions de ce
jour pour poser les bases définitive de
la gouvernance régionale de la BPI BPI
et région pourront ainsi mettre leur
action en cohérence et investir ensemble
dans les entreprises de croissance par
exemple elles pourront créer deux
concerts des fonds communs
d'intervention en lien avec le schéma
régional de développement économique et
un chiffre un seul chiffre résume à lui
seul l'ambition de proximité que je veux
porter à travers la BPI et sa
crédibilité 90 % des décisions
financières seront prises au niveau
régional donc au plus près du terrain et
des entreprises nous avons voulu une BPI
ancré dans les territoires associant
l'État et les régions et c'est pour moi
pas seulement un choix politique mais
une condition essentielle du succès de
ce grand projet je sais que c'est un
point aussi auquel cette chambre est
parement sensible je crois que le texte
que vous examinez maintenant répond de
manière convaincante sur ce point même
si il peut toujours être amélioré et là
encore je suis disponible pour examiner
les amendements que votre sagesse
suggérera j'espère j'espère en effet que
la discussion devant le Sénat sera
l'occasion d'améliorer encore le texte
je pense pense au traitement spécifique
de l'outremire je pense aux zones
d'intervention de la BPI nous devons
lever l'ambiguïé du texte sur ce point
la BPI a bien vocation et je le dis
d'emblé ce qui veut dire que
j'accueillerai avec faveur des
amendements qui iraient dans ce sens
vocation à sououtenir le développement
des entreprises dans les zones rurales
je pense à certains éléments de la
doctrine d'intervention de la BPI qui ne
relève pas de la loi mais qui mérite une
discussion ici entre nous je pense à
l'association des autres collectivités à
l'action de la BPI et des régions je
voudrais finir en élargissant un peu la
focale et en restituant ce projet de loi
très important que vous examinez dans le
cadre plus large de l'action globale que
je porte pour le financement de
l'économie cette action elle se déploie
sur plusieurs dimensions complémentaires
nous mettrons d'abord la finance au
service de l'économie réelle grâce à une
réforme bancaire que je présenterai la
semaine prochaine au Conseil des
ministres et qui va séparer les
activités spéculatives
des banques des activités dont
l'économie a besoin je respecte les
entrepreneurs j'aime l'entreprise mais
je ne comprends pas que la finance
spécule pour son propre compte je
n'approuve pas qu'elle le fasse les
banques doivent se recentrer sur leur
cœur de métier et ce sera ça la
philosophie du projet de loi qui vous
sera soumis la création d'une nouvelle
bourse pour les PME et ETI en 2013
interviendra aussi dans cette optique
car là encore il s'agit de remettre la
bourse au service des entreprises et non
l'inverse en même temps il faut élargir
considérablement les possibilités
d'accès des petites et moyennes
entreprises au marché financiers au
marché en action c'est une condition
leur développement enfin parce que la
BPI n'a ni pour ambition ni pour
vocation de répondre à l'ensemble des
défaillances de marché je présenterai en
2013 des mesures pour réformer la
fiscalité de l'épargne sur la base des
travaux de deux députés madame Karine
berger Monsieur Dominique Lefèvre cette
réforme elle aura pour objectif de
canaliser l'épargne des Français qui est
abondante vers l'économie productive
elle encouragera le renforcement des
fonds propre en favorisant le dépargne
de le développement de l'épargne
financière de long terme en complément
de la réforme de l'épargne réglementé
déjà bien avancé l'argent des Français
doit aller financer le développement de
nos entreprises vous voyez que le
gouvernement agit de la sorte dans
plusieurs dimensions pour mieux financer
l'économie nous mettons en place les
outils pour répondre à l'ensemble des
besoins de financement entreprises au
travers de la BPI une structure unie une
structure innovante une structure
exemplaire une structure proche des PME
des ETI une structure puissante et
efficace verra le jour avec votre
concours ce projet vous le savez tous
vous le vivez dans vos départements dans
vos régions il est très attentu il a
fait l'objet d'une élaboration à la fois
rapide car il fallait aller vite dès
lors qu'il y avait cette attente donc ce
besoin il fallait le satisfaire mais
aussi d'une élaboration très approfondie
une mission de réfiguration a été
confiée un inspecteur général des
finances monsieur parent qui a fait un
travail tout à fait important sur la
base duquel avec des discussions qui
n'ont pas été sans vivacité on a pu
fonder le texte de loi le texte de loi
comme la structure de BPI ont été
fortement amélioré le travail du
rapporteur général que je salue à
nouveau nos échanges à l'Assemblée ici
le travail des rapporteurs tout ça
contribue à améliorer le projet et le
débat que nous aurons permettra de
finaliser ces progrès moi j'ai une
conviction je l'ai déjà exprimé à
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai la conviction
que ce projet de loi perfectionné par
vos travaux porte une grande cause une
cause d'intérêt général je dirais même
d'intérêt national qui peut nous
rassembler tous sur tous les bancs c'est
celle du financement de l'investissement
celle de la compétitivité de notre
économie celle du développement de nos
entreprises nos territoirees celle du
redressement de notre pays je je ne sais
toujours pas quel a été le vote de
l'opposition à l'Assemblée nationale
parce que il s'est passé un événement
assez extraordinaire et pour moi
totalement inédit c'est que il n'y avait
aucun député de l'opposition au moment
du vote ce qui rend compliqué
l'interprétation de leur sens mais ce ne
sera pas le cas ici au Sénat je le sais
et et et c'est la raison pour laquelle
me tournant aussi vers l'opposition et
évidemment vers la majorité mais qui a
été uni et rassemblé à l'Assemblée
j'espère un vote très large et pourquoi
pas puisqu'il s'agit d'une cause
d'intérêt national un vote unanime sur
ce texte ma conviction pour y avoir
beaucoup travailler c'est vraiment qu'il
le mérite et que votre vote à tous est
attendu et qu'il sera compris compris
surtout s'il est positif je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur François Marc
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la
création de la Banque publique
d'investissement va bientôt devenir une
réalité
et en tant que rapporteur des deux
textes soumis à notre examen en tant que
membre de la
majorité parlementaire qui soutient
l'action du Président de la République
et donc de son gouvernement je ne peux
m'empêcher de dire toute ma
satisfaction tout d'abord de la promesse
tenue car la naissance de la BPI était
le premier des engagements pris par
François Hollande devant les
Français satisfaction de pouvoir appuyer
ici au Sénat l'éclosion d'une grande
d'un grand groupe public qui sera
présent sur l'ensemble de la chaîne du
financement des entreprises et
satisfaction aussi de voir bientôt mis à
disposition des
entrepreneurs un outil qui soutiendra
leur action en matière d'innovation et
qui pourra leur permettre d'obtenir des
financements le cas échéant en
entraînant les banques à sa suite ou
encore de stabiliser leur
actionnariat certes nul ne conteste
qu'avant la BPI l'État n'est pas resté
les bras croisés face aux difficultés de
financement des entreprises et
singulièrement des PME il y a lieu de
faire état à cet égard du plan de
sauvetage des banques mis en place en
octobre
2008 du plan de soutien spécifique pour
le financement des PME mis en œuvre ce
même mois puis développé par la suite
qui comprenait notamment
l'augmentation de la capacité
d'intervention d'OSO l'octroit de la
garantie de l' la Caisse Centrale de
Réassurance pour soutenir l'assurance
crédit et l'installation d'un médiateur
du crédit aux
entreprises et je n'oublie pas non plus
en matière d'investissement capital la
naissance du fond stratégique
d'investissement à qui il revient
d'apporter des fonds propres aux
entreprises afin d'accélérer leur
développement d'accompagner leur
transformation dans des périodes de
mutation ou de stabiliser leur
actionnariat
à l'époque mes chers collègues à
l'époque la gauche ne s'était pas opposé
à l'action du gouvernement de François
Fillon sur ces
sujets j'espère donc qu'aujourd'hui et
le ministre y a fait allusion tout à
l'heure j'espère donc qu'aujourd'hui nos
collègues de l'opposition auront aussi à
cœur d'aborder ce débat dans le même
état d'esprit au service de l'économie
de notre pays et sans illère
partisane cependant si les actions
conduites sont globalement allés dans le
bon sens le paysage du financement
public des entreprises reste beaucoup
trop éclaté et
emprint de complexité à cet égard je
vous invite à consulter un schéma
évocateur élaboré par la Mission parent
de préfiguration de la BPI et repris en
page 19 de l'étude d'impact annexé au
projet de loi qui retrace les liens
entre tous ces opérateurs le moins que
l'on puisse dire et qu'il ne brille pas
par sa simplicité et on imagine bien la
perplexité des dirigeants de PME qui
auraient besoin d'un soutien public
quand il s'agit de savoir à quelle porte
il faut frapper ces failles que l'on
constate sur le terrain se retrouvent
aussi au niveau stratégique aujourd'hui
chacun définit sa stratégie de son côté
isolément sans vision de ce que font les
autres et de ce que serait la meilleure
manière d'articuler l'action
publique alors le premier objectif de la
BPI sa première mission c'est justement
d'apporter une réponse au problème ainsi
soulevé mes chers collègues nous le
savons la banque publique
d'investissement regroupera en son sein
AUO le fond stratégique d'investissement
et CDC entreprise elle distribuera
également les produits de la cofas et du
bifance en attendant peut-être un
rapprochement avec cet établissement
public dans les années à
venir imaginons la simplification
radicale qui en résultera pour les
dirigeants de PME ils pourront trouver
dans un même endroit prês de chez eux en
région en proximité avec leur entreprise
un prêteur un garant un
investisseur un gestionnaire de fond et
un soutien à l'exportation il est clair
mes chers collègues que c'est sur le
terrain que la BPI devra ainsi faire la
preuve de sa valeur ajoutée
c'est à ce niveau qu'elle devra être
connue de tous et avoir la confiance de
ses
clients mes chers collègues vous le
savez au niveau centrale la banque
publique d'investissement sera comme son
nom l'indique un groupe public à 100 %
public puisque ces deux actionnaires
seront à parité l'État au travers d'un
établissement public dénommé BP Group et
la Caisse des dépôts et consignations
chaque actionnaire apportera ses parts
dans les sociétés qu'il dé
et qui seront intégrés dans la
BPI monsieur le ministre même si votre
Ministre délégué Benoît amamont nous a
donné des éléments en commission des
finances la semaine
dernière je pense qu'il est important
sans vouloir sombrer dans ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier de pointillisme d'un
notaire de demander à ce que soit
repréciser devant le Sénat dans quel
calendrier les dernières tranches des
augmentations de capital du FSI est dosé
et haut doivent être
libérés nous parlons en effet de montant
relativement conséquent côté F cela
représente 3,6 milliards d'euros dont
1,7 milliard d'euros pour l'État et 1,9
d'euros pour la CDC pour Oso cela
représente 500 millions d'euros 365
millions d'euros pour l'État et 135 pour
la CDC ceci sur le milliard d'euros de
recapitalisation qui devait s'opérer à
la suite de la création de la filiale
industrie par la loi de finance
rectificative du 14 mars 2012 la fameuse
banque de l'industrie où il y avait des
engagements qui avaient été pris
d'apporter de la
recapitalisation en tout état de cause
la BPI que nous allons mettre en place
aura une capacité d'action tout à fait
importante côté crédit en reprenant le
profil de risque actuel des prêts
octroyés par auoso la capacité totale
des prêts du groupe devrait être de
l'ordre de 20000 milliard
d'euros avec l'effet d'entraînement de
ces prêts sur les banques privées en
moyenne on sait qu'elle est de 1 pour un
les concours bancaires totaux à
destination des PME et des ETI qui en
seraient issu devrai donc représenter un
total de 40 milliards d'euros en outre
la capacité de prise de risque en
garantie totale de cet établissement
s'élèverait à 13 milliards d'euros ce
qui permettrait là aussi de faciliter
l'oroit de plus de 26 d'euros de
concours bancaire
supplémentaire enfin la capacité de la
branche innovation qui dépend des
dotations budgétaires du niveau de
risque retenu serait de l'ordre de 600
millions d'euros par an pour le soutien
individuel et collaboratif de projets
innovant et enfin côté investissement en
capital il est prévu une capacité
d'intervention de l'ordre de 1,8
milliards d'euros par an et de plus
comme je l'ai souligné la BPI sera
étroitement associé à ubiifrance et à la
cofas dont elle distribuera les produits
dans son réseau la BPI groupe financier
public aura donc les moyens de sa
politique elle sera en mesure d'imprimer
une stratégie cohérente de financement
public de l'économie et des entreprises
en particulier des PME et des sociétés
innovantes et
exportatrices bien entendu afin d'agir
efficacement elle devra avoir accès à
des ressources financière en quantité
suffisante et aux meilleures conditions
possibles et à ce de ce point de vue
monsieur le mini nous savons certains
dans cet hémicycle command dehor
craignent que paradoxalement à l'issue
de la création de la BPI le nouvel
établissement se refinance à des
conditions moins avantageuses que
l'actuel
Oso certains amendements s'alimentent
d'ailleurs d'une telle crainte
et nous aurons à en débattre cette
crainte tient au choix de la structure
du groupe retenu par les deux
actionnaires qui consiste à placer à la
tête de l'ensemble une holding fêtière
dénommé BPI group chapautant l'ensemble
des filiales opérationnelles et certains
se demandent en particulier si le fait
de placer un niveau d'interposition
entre des actionnaires à la solidité
incontestable
et à la filiale active en matière de
crédit ne perturbera pas les
investisseurs susceptibles de souscrire
les émissions obligataires de cette
dernière et puis d'autres s'interrogent
quant à la capacité de la BPI à se
refinancer auprès de la Banque centrale
européenne je crois donc nécessaire
monsieur le ministre que vous puissiez
rassurer le Sénat sur ces différents
points que vous nous confirmiez que les
émissions du nouvel ensemble bénéfici on
toujours de la garantie de
l'établissement public BPI Group et que
vous puissiez nous éclairer sur les
raisons qui ont poussé l'État et la CDC
à privilégier le schéma ainsi
retenu mes chers collègues je vous l'ai
dit dans banque publique
d'investissement il y a banque
publique il s'agit d'un élément fort
d'identité une banque publique ne doit
pas être une banque comme les
autres tout en agissant naturellement en
investisseur avisé elle doit savoir
faire ce que les autres ne font pas
elle doit savoir se montrer audacieuse
et prendre certains risques qui en
valent la peine
elle doit se montrer présente sur ces
segments que les banques classiques ne
financent pas ou ne financent pas seul
et dont notre économie a pourtant tant
besoin je veux parler des entreprises en
amorçage des petites et moyennes
entreprises manufacturièes du secteur
industriel
ou encore des PME exportatrices la BPI
doit savoir oser elle doit pouvoir
entraîner les autres à sa
suite la BPI doit aussi faire reposer
son action sur des
principes en commission des finances
certains ont
ironisé mais et nous assumons et nous
sommes même fiers que le Parlement se
soucie de valeur quand il crée une
banque
publique nous assumons que cette banque
a à soutenir l'emploi et la
compétitivité de l'économie nous
assumons qu'elle est à appuyer les
politiques publiques tournées vers les
secteurs
d'avenir nous assumons qu'elle est
vocation à mettre en œuvre la transition
écologique nous assumons de la même
façon que la BPI soit soucieuse quand
elle intervient de prendre en compte
dans ses pratiques les enjeux
environnementaux sociaux ou encore
d'égalité professionnelle qu'elle ne se
résume pas en un mot à un animal
financier à sans
froid ce choix de ne pas tourner le dos
au monde dans lequel elle vivra se
reflète aussi dans ses futurs modes de
gouvernance au sommet un conseil
d'administration aura évidemment à
prendre les décisions les plus
importantes qui engageront son avenir
c'est là une chose
normale mais nous assumons le choix de
placer à côté de ce conseil un comité
national d'orientation présidé par un
président de région par définition
impliqué au premier chef dans la vie
économique de son territoire qui
s'exprimera sur les orientations
stratégiques de la BPI sur sa doctrine
d'intervention et sur la façon dont elle
doit remplir ses missions d'intérêt
général
nous assumons aussi le choix de décliner
ce comité au niveau
régional près de l'économie réel afin
d'articuler au mieux l'action de tous
les acteurs publics d'un territoire et
de faire de que l'action de la BPI soit
pleinement cohérente avec les stratégies
régionales de développement
économique et nous assumons enfin le
choix de faire de la BPI une banque
exemplaire dans un monde fin
très largement dominé par des hommes en
affichant la parité entre les femmes et
les hommes à tous les étages de
gouvernance comités régionaux
d'orientation comité national
d'orientation et conseil
d'administration et je rends à cet égard
hommage mes chers collègues à l'esprit
pionnier du Sénat et de Jean-Vincent
plaier qui est avec nous qui avait déjà
pour le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques oser préconiser que dans la
sphère financière on puisse faire
apparaître la parité dans les postes de
responsabilité et nous avons trouvé ici
une concrétisation nouvelle de ce
principe cependant mes chers collègues
les parlementaires que nous sommes
doivent savoir rester modeste mais nous
sénateurs nous le savons fort bien une
fois que nous aurons voté ce texte une
fois que nous aurons contribuer à faire
exister la banque publique
d'investissement l'essentiel restera à
faire
cette banque en effet ce n'est pas nous
qui la bâtirons ce seront les personnes
qui travailleront au premier desquels le
futur directeur général de la société de
tête la société anonyme BPI Group et on
peut penser qu'il faudra beaucoup de
finesse et de volonté pour rassembler
des énergies aujourd'hui épars et pour
faire de différentes maisons à la
culture d'entreprise diverses et forte
un ensemble harmonieux qui sache marcher
d'un seul pas
il faudra de l'énergie pour définir une
stratégie précise et pour la décliner
sur le terrain bref en la matière le
choix des personnes compte il est même
capital c'est pourquoi il m'a paru
indispensable que le directeur général
futur chef d'orchestre de la banque
publique d'investissement soit choisi en
associant le Parlement c'est-à-dire
après la procédure d'avis public des
commissions compétentes définies au 5e
linat de l'article 13 de la Constitution
comme l' d'ailleurs actuellement le
patron
d'OSO j'ai donc déposé le 23 octobre
dernier une proposition de loi organique
en ce sens et je suis heureux que nous
ayons à débattre en même temps que le
projet de loi relatif à la création de
la BPI d'une proposition de loi
organique adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale dans le même esprit nous avons
sur un point modifié le texte des
députés lors de la réunion de la
commission des finances monsieur le
ministre mercredi dernier il nous a paru
opportun de limiter l'usage de cette
procédure solennelle et contraignante à
la nomination du seul directeur général
de la société anonyme sans y ajouter
comme l'Assemblée nationale l'avait
imaginé celle du président de
l'établissement public BPI Group ne nous
a pas semblé que cette dernière
nomination soit particulièrement
stratégique dans un nouveau contexte où
celui-ci aura principalement pour rôle
de porter la participation de l'État et
je suis heureux que le gouvernement et
partagé cette analyse quand nous avons
examiné cet amendement donner l'onction
parlementaire à plusieurs personnalité
d'un même ensemble au sens large peut
contribuer à créer des conflits de
légitimité qui n'ont pas lieu d'être il
est au contraire plus clair que la BPI
n'est à sa tête qu'un dirigeant ainsi
désigné monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègu cheminant vers ma conclusion je
veux simplement émettre le souhait que
la création de la Banque publique
d'investissement puisse rassembler toute
la majorité bien sûr mais qu'elle nous
Perm d'aller au-delà des clivages
partisans ce projet de loi rationalise
des structures utiles mais que nous
avons empilé sans y prendre garde et
sans leur donner une feuille de route
commune il va plus loin que ce qu'on
fait Jacques Chirac en créant Oso et
Nicolas Sarkozi en augmentant la voilure
de ce même Oso et en créant le FSI pour
autant ce projet de loi voulu et porté
par François Hollande ne s'inscrit pas
en opposition avec l'action de ses
prédécesseurs la motivation est la même
la motivation est la même seule
l'ambition est ici un peu plus étendue
les moyens et l'ex et l'exemplarité nous
l'avons vu seront au rendez-vous ce
projet de loi est une chance pour notre
économie et pour nos entreprise c'est
donc avec conviction que je vous appelle
à l'adopter je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général la
parole est à Monsieur Martial Bourquin
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires
économiques monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues le
projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui met en œuvre le premier des
60 engagements du Président de la
République celui de créer une banque
publique
d'investissement ce sera un outil
essentiel pour le rétablissement de la
compétitivité de notre pays un outil au
service d'une politique de croissance
durable et d'emploi chers collègues nous
le savons tous les TPE les PME les ETI
de notre pays ont du mal à financer leur
projet de
développement lors de la visite en
Allemagne dans le bas
berg nous avions pu assister à la
puissance industrielle allemande
avec ses
clusters avec ses écosystèmes productifs
mais aussi avec cette banque
d'investissement public qui aidaient les
petites et moyennes entreprises et créer
des véritables politiques de
filièr les critères aujourd'hui de
rentabilité de risque des finan priv
notamment des banques empêche nous le
savons tous un nombre de projets
innovants
d'éclore c'est le constat de ces
défaillances du marché qui justifi en
premier lieu l'intervention financière
des pouvoir public cette intervention
ayant pour objectif d'entraîner les
financeurs privés par des mécanismes de
cofinancement l'idée le principe c'est
le principe
d'entraînement la nécessité de cette
action publique est admise depuis
longtemps vous connaissez tous et nous
connaissons le rôle
d'OSEO le rôle de la Caisse des dépôts
dans ce domaine d'abord je tiens à
souligner la qualité du travail réalisé
par ces institutions il y a chez OSEO
une culture de la
proximité une culture de la simplicité
une culture de la réactivité qui est
appréciée des entreprises il y a dans
les filiales de la caiss des dépôts
une vraie expertise dans le domaine des
fonds propres et sans elle disons-le
aujourd'hui le marché français du
capital investissement serait
complètement
sinistré la finalité de la création de
la BPI n'est donc pas de sanctionner une
carence des outils existants mais au
contraire de s'appuyer sur des
compétences et des qualités reconnues
pour leur offrir un cadre plus ambitieux
capable de mieux répondre aux
insuffisances actuelles du financement
de notre
économie notre dispositif d'appui
financier aux entreprises est en effet
comme ça a été dit avant moi trop
complexe trop dispersé l'état la Caisse
de dépôt et les régions agissent au
travers des dispositifs incroyaable
incroyablement nombreux et divers cela
pose un problème évident de cohérence
dans le pilotage d'ensemble et depuis
plusieurs années il y a eu des efforts
important pour que les acteurs
communiquent mieux à la fois au plan
stratégique à la fois au plan
opérationnel mais aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit qu'il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin la BPI va permettre
l'intégration de zoo et des filièles de
la caiss de dépôt dans un ensemble
bénéficiant désormais d'une direction
unique et mettant en œuvre une stratégie
définie de façon plus cohérente et
l'Association des Régions à la
gouvernance de la BPI ira dans le même
sens l'objectif final de cette
rationalisation du dispositif n'est
évidemment pas de créer un beau schéma
sur le papier il est de mettre fin à
l'empilement des outils de financement
sur le terrain et donc de rendre l'offre
de financement public plus lusible plus
accessible et cela au quotidien pour les
entreprises cela réponds à une demande
du monde économique j'ai reçu les les
représentants de la CG PME qui m'ont
confirmé cette exigence de
rationalisation le grand le second grand
objectif de la création de la BPI est de
renforcer les liens entre les outils de
financement et la stratégie de
développement économique tant au niveau
nationale que régionale et ça c'est
aussi un aspect très important la BPI
aura d'un côté une mission de
financement qu'on pourrait qualifier de
général ou de systémique en direction
des PME pe toute entreprise ayant un
projet des difficultés à le financer
pourra s'adresser à elle mais la BPI
aura aussi et cela est beaucoup plus
novateur une mission de financement
ciblé sur des priorités nationales
définies par l'État par ce dernier
aspect la BPI ne se ne se situera pas
strictement dans le domaine des
justifications à l'intervention
économique de l'État qui est de palier
les les défaillances du marché elle se
rattachera une tradition différente
celle de l'État stratège celle de l'État
organisateur la bpievendra en appui j'y
reviendrai des grandes priorités dans le
domaine de la politique industrielle
comme l'a rappelé tout à l'heure le
ministre notamment en matière
d'organisation des filières parce que
sans politique de filière il n'y a pas
de politique industrielle viable ou
encore dans la le domaine de la
transition écologique énergétique je ne
reviens pas sur la présentation du
schéma d'organisation et des règles de
gouvernance prévues par la BPI car le
ministre et le rapporteur général l'ont
déjà fait la
position des affaires économiques du
Sénat est que le texte a atteint sur ces
questions un point d'équilibre
satisfaisant je tiens d'ailleurs à
saluer tant la qualité du texte initial
transmis au Parlement que la qualité du
travail d'amendement réalisé par les
députés et nos collègues de la
commission des finances parmi les
changements apportés au texte qu' me
semble important de souligner je citerai
en particulier l'introduction du
principe de parité dans les organes de
gouvernance de la BPI cela répond comme
la représentation des salariés au
conseil d'administration un souci
d'exemplarité de la gouvernance de la
banque de même il faut se féliciter du
renforcement du contrôle du du Parlement
sur la BPI c'est une disposition
d'autant plus nécessaire que ce projet
pose un cadre d'action général et qu'une
grande partie de la réforme va se tenir
dans la mise en œuvre opérationnelle de
la nouvelle banque le Parlement doit
avoir un droit de regard sur cette phase
opérationnelle nos débats aujourd'hui
permettront d'apporter quelques avancées
supplémentaires je présenterai
d'ailleurs au nom de la comm des
affaires économiques un certain nombre
d'amendements toutefois il me paraît
utile comme certains ontmis le souhait
de ne pas et de préciser de ne pas
modifier profondément l'organisation de
la BPI par rapport au schéma prévu il
est satisfaisant des schémas alternatifs
ont été évoqués dans la presse l'un de
propose de remonter la filiale crédit
correspondant à l'actuel AUO pour en
faire la tête de groupe le principal
argument
avanc et financier actuellement la Sao
finance en effet son activité de crédit
en levant des fonds sur les marchés
financiers elle le fait un coût très
faible taux souverain plus de 20 points
de base parce que du point de vue des
marché la Sao bénéficie de la garantie
totale de l'État français via lespic au
zoo si certains craignent que le nouvel
organogramme dans lequel la holding BPI
s'intercale entre l'État et la F et la
filiale crédit soit perçu comme une
forme de désengagement de l'État et que
cela aboutisse à un coût de
refinancement plus important mais
écoutez chers collègues je n'y crois pas
un instant la filiale crédit de la BPI
dans le schéma du projet de loi est
adossée à une tête de groupe qui
bénéficie à 100 % de de la garantie de
l'État et de la CDC la qualité de
signature est équivalente la garantie
des pouvoirs publics dans la BPI crédit
est donc totale et d'ailleurs comm comme
elle est déjà reconnue par les marchés
si ces derniers qui connaissent depuis
plusieurs semaines l'organisation prévue
pour la BPI avait un doute sur la
qualité des émissions BPI crédit il
aurait déjà exprimé par une perte de
confiance à Oso qui est appelé à devenir
cette filale de crédit or les taux de
refinancement d'so ne se sont pas
détériorés par ailleurs je tiens à le
rappeler faire remonter auzo en position
de tête de groupe ferait entrer les
banques privées actionnaires d'
dans le capital de la société maire à
hauteur de 2 % ces banques seraient donc
représenté dans le conseil
d'administration ce qui ne me paraît pas
souhaitable la BPI doit rester une
banque
publique certains voudrait aussi
renforcer davantage la place des régions
et là le ministre l'a précisé tout à
l'heure des ajustements sont évidemment
souhaitable et possible et je vous
proposerai d'ailleurs un amendement dans
ce sens essentiel c'est qu'on reste dans
le cadre d'uneation une association
étroite des régions à la gouvernance de
la BPI mais sans remettre en cause la
responsabilité première de l'État dans
son pilotage cette formule est juste et
équilibrée d'un côté en effet les
régions font beaucoup pour accompagner
les entreprises sur leur territoire
elles sont en lien avec les communautés
urbaines les communautés d'agglomération
les communautés de communes les
départements elles ont un savoir-faire
maintenant historique et il serait
dommage de se priver de ce savoir-faire
il est donc essentiel que la gouvernance
de la BPI reflète cette réalité pour
autant le pilotage stratégique de la BPI
doit rester sous la responsabilité
première de l'État et son pilotage
opérationnel sous la responsabilité de
son directeur général la BPI est en
effet comme on le disait tout à l'heure
un outil au service d'une stratégie
nationale de soutien aux entreprises
de restauration de la compétitivité de
la stimulation de la croissance et de
l'emploi son capital sera détenu à
parité par deux acteurs l'État et la CDC
dont le périmètre d'action les objectifs
sont clairement du ressort national
voilà donc pour la position que nous
avons dégagé en commission des affaires
économiques j'en viens maintenant aux
missions et à la doctrine d'intervention
de la
BP dans sa rédaction initiale l'article
1er du texte qui définit ses missions
était très concis pour ne pas dire
parfois elliptique l'essentiel était dit
c'est vrai mais on restait un peu sur sa
fin cont tenu de l'importance du du
texte les députés ont donc opportunément
introduit plusieurs précisions pour
mieux fixer le cadre d'action de la BPI
ils ont tout d'abord clairement indiqué
que la BPI orientera en priorité son
action vers les TPE les PME les ETI en
particulier dans le secteur industriel
et bien cette précision est importante
ils ont aussi mieux défini le champ de
son offre en précisant qu'elle
développera une offre de service et
d'accompagnement des entreprises dans
leur projets de développement on pas
chers collègues ainsi d'une offre de
produits financiers strict au sensu à
une offre intégrée mêlant à la fois
produits financiers et service
d'accompagnement on le sait chers
collègues quand une entreprise est
accompagné il a beaucoup plus de chances
de réussir c'est un point qui me paraît
essentiel le BPI ne sera pas simplement
un guichet qui offre un catalogue de
produits standardisés répondant à des
besoins de financement prédéfinis les
chargés d'affaires de la BPI devront
entrer dans un dialogue stratégique avec
les entreprises en leur apportant un
regard extérieur une analyse un conseil
sur le possibilité de développement
l'enjeu est les guider vers les bons
outils de les pousser à l'innovation à
la croissance à la recherche de gain
dans l'efficacité opérationnelle cela se
fait déjà en parti bien sûr mais de
manière informelle désormais la loi
systématise cette démarche en
l'inscrivant dans les missions mêmees de
la BPI au passage cela justifie d'autant
plus la fusion du B France au sein de la
BPI puisque le métier du B France est
axé sur l'accompagnement vers l'export
les députés ont
également explicité la doctrine de la
banque elle interviendra
en investisseur avisés de long terme et
agira en complémentarité avec les
acteurs financiers privés en favorisant
la mobilisation de l'ensemble du système
bancaire sur les projets qu'elle
soutient je tiens cependant à souligner
qu'elle ne fera pas que cela dans le
domaine des subventions à l'innovation
et des interventions en garantie on est
en effet sur des opérations souvent où
le marché est absent ce qui justifie
pleinement une intervention selon des
critères d'intérêt général par ailleurs
les députés ont précisé la fonction
stratégique de la Bpi en indiquant
qu'elle vient en appui de différentes
stratégies nationales elle accompagnera
la politique industrielle notamment pour
soutenir les stratégies de développement
de filière elle participera au
développement des secteurs d'avenir de
la conversion num
de l'économie sociale et solidaire elle
contribuera à la mise en œuvre de la
transition écologique
elle pourra stabiliser l'actionnariat
des de grandes entreprises porteuses de
croissance et de compétitivité pour
l'économie française le rôle stratégique
de l'État est donc bien affirmé au total
il me semble que sur la question des
missions de la BPI le texte tel qu'il
est sorti de l'Assemblée nationale est
globalement satisfaisant je vous
présenterai seulement quelques
amendements mais qui rien qui le if pas
de façon substantielle à cet égard je
tiens d'ailleurs à attirer votre
attention sur la néité de garder à la
BPI une priorité d'action clairement
défin à l'annonce de la création et le
ministre en effet l'écho tout à
l'heure cela a nourri beaucoup d'attente
et d'espéran fortes si forte et si
diverse qu'elle pourrait placer la BPI
devant un risque paradoxal être victime
de son succès on voit bien en effet que
tous les acteurs publics privé dont les
besoins de financement ont du mal à être
satisfaits par des mécanismes privés
voit dans la BPI une réponse potentielle
à leur difficultés cependant il faut
être clair la BPI n'a pas vocation à
devenir l'outil unique et polyvalent de
l'intervention économique publique
elle est et doit rester d'une part un
outil d'appui au financement des
entreprises prioritairement les TPE les
PME les ETI indépendantes et d'autre
part le bras financier d'une stratégie
nationale de compétitivité et de
croissance une dilution de ces mission
conduirait un souspoudrage des
interventions à une perte d'efficacité
et comme vous le savez en effet le
volume de moyens mis à la disposition de
la BPI sera besoin est voisin de celui
dont dispose actuellement AUO et la CDC
ajouter des missions nouvelles à moyen
constant impliquerait une dégradation
des missions fondamentales en
particulier la problématique du
financement des collectivités
territoriales parce qu'il y a eu le
débat en commission ne relève pas
d'émission de la BPI il y a de vraies
questions à régler dans ce domaine mais
la réponse n'est pas la BPI il y a
d'autres outils adapté à cette
problématique je veux parler de
l'enveloppe de 20 milliards annoncé
récemment par le gouvernement et la mise
en place d'une banque spécialisée dans
le financement des collectivités sous la
houlette de la Banque Postale et la
caise des dépôts la BPI n'est pas non
plus un outil d'aménagement économique
du territoire certes certes l'appui
financier et l'autre et la dernière fois
il y a de quelques jours le président
des régions de France est venu nous dire
que 60 % des entreprises
était dans le le territoire
rural et que l'appui au PME TPE ne peut
contribuer Infiné au développement du
tissu commercial du tissu productif de
proximité participant de ce fait à
l'aménagement du territoire cependant
l'existence ou la recherche de
convergence entre l'action de la BPI et
les stratégies d'aménagement du
territoire n'implique pas que la BPI a
vocation à se substituer aux outil aux
outils conçus spécifiques pour remédier
aux difficultés réelles endémiques que
connaissent nos territoires ruraux ou
urbains et quelle est vocation à venir
compenser l'assèchement financier de
certains de ces dispositifs je veux
citer notamment le FISAC qui a été
complètement vidé de ses moyens dans la
la dernière loi de
finances enfin la BPI n'est pas non plus
une banque hôpitale pour reprendre
l'expression utilisée par Monsieur
dufourc lors de son audition elle pourra
bien sûr intervenir auprès d'entreprises
qui connaissent des difficultés
passagères de nature conjoncturelle une
crise de trésorerie une insuffisance
temporaire du carnet de commande mais
aussi structurelle mais elle ne devra
intervenir qu'auprès des entreprises qui
ont des chances raisonnables de rebond
pour finir permettez-moi de souligner
deux idées importantes notre économie
traverse actuellement une crise grave il
est important que la BPI soit en mesure
de répondre de façon réactive aux
difficultés conjoncturelles pour limiter
l'ampleur de l'impact mais au-delà de
son rôle contracyclique la BPI est avant
tout un outil destiné à poser les bases
d'un financement sain de nos entreprises
à long terme ce n'est pas qu'un il de
réponse à la crise c'est avant tout un
outil financier de reconquête de la
croissance ma deuxième remarque complète
la précédence la BPI n'est elle- même
qu'un aspect de la politique générale de
redressement industriel et productif
engagé par le président de la République
et le Premier ministre et son
gouvernement c'est une pièce dans un
vaste édifice en train de se mettre en
place la BPI s'inscrit dans une réforme
global du financement de notre économie
réforme qui comprendra une réforme
bancaire pour parer des activités
spéculatives des activités de
financement de l'économie réelle ainsi
que la création d'une nouvelle bourse
pour les PME ETI dans ce chantier de
financement il faudra sans doute se
pencher sur la question des délais de
paiement du crédit interentreprise enfin
la réforme de financement s'inscrit à
son tour dans un Pact de compétitivité
plus global qui imp qui implique des
réformes fortes dans le domaine de la
compétitivité coût et he coût
ce texte contribue donc à remettre
l'économie française dans le sens de la
marche et il faut s'en
féliciter merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur André verretto
rapporteur pour avis de la commission du
développement durable des
infrastructures de l'équipement et de
l'aménagement du
territoire monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la commission qui m'a fait l'honneur de
me désigner rapporteur pour avis sur ce
projet de loi est compétente en matière
de développement durable et
d'aménagement du territoire c'est donc
principalement sous ces deux angles que
j'ai examiné le projet de loi dont nous
discutons
aujourd'hui les orateurs qui m'ont
précédé ont rappelé que la création de
la Banque publique d'investissement la
BPI était le premier des 60 engagements
du Président de la République lors de la
campagne pour l'élection
présidentielle l'objectif annoncé était
de palier les carences des banques
privées dans le financement des projets
portés par les petites et moyennes
entreprises aujourd'hui la BPI se trouve
au cœur du dispositif de reconquête de
la compétitivité française il s'agit
d'apporter un soutien aux entreprises
très petites entreprises PME
établissement de taille intermédiaire et
de créer un levier pour les financements
privés ce faisant il s'agit d'abord de
remédier aux faiblesses du financement
de notre tissu productif celle sont bien
connu elles se traduisent par les
difficultés d'accès des entreprises au
crédit bancairirees à des fonds propres
au financement à l'export par le recul
du capital investissement mais aussi par
l'empilement des outils de financement
et des interlocuteurs ainsi que par
l'éparpillement des dispositifs
existant dans une étude récente la
Banque centrale européenne a pointé que
parmi les difficultés auxquelles sont
confrontés les PME en Europe l'accès au
financement arrive en 2e position cité
par 18 18 % des entrepreneurs interrogés
après la recherche de nouveaux clients
et de nouveaux débouchés mais il s'agit
aussi de créer un mécanisme destiné à
s'intégrer dans une politique
industrielle définie par l'État et
portée par les territoires afin
d'encourager les créations d'emplois de
favoriser la croissance et de lancer la
transition
écologique ce dernier objectif a été
clairement affirmé en septembre dernier
lors de la conférence environnementale
par le Président de la République qui
avait alors indiqué que la pays allait
je cite concentrer une bonne part de ces
interventions sur la conversion
écologique de notre système productifs
qu'il s'agisse de l'isolation thermique
des énergies renouvelables ou des
écotechnologies nous le savons bien mes
chers collègues cet engagement est
essentiel et chacun se réjouit qu'il
trouve aujourd'hui sa traduction
législative dans ce projet de loi la
transition écologique ne porte pas
uniquement sur les filières vertes
traditionnelles que sont les
écotechnologies ou les les énergies
renouvelables l'objectif est bel et bien
de toucher chaque pan de l'économie
française et de provoquer un
verdissement des activités
traditionnelles il s'agit de changer de
paradigme économique et social le
programme d'investissement à réaliser
pour financer la transition écologique
est estimé par les spécialistes à un
montant de 2 à 3 % du PIB par an pendant
au moins 10 ans soit pour la France un
total de 600 milliards d'euros environ
le programme des Nations Unis pour
l'environnement recommande de son côté
d'investir 2 % du PS du PIB mondial dans
les investissements de transition
écologique tous les spécialistes
insistent sur le fait que ces
investissements et ces transitions
écologiques ne doivent pas être perçu
comme un coût B est bien compris mais
bel et bien compris comme une chance
pour l'emploi et la croissance certes
les sommes nécessaires apparaissent
considérable mais ce sont généralement
des investissements territorialisés donc
peu délocalisables et riches en emploi
de proximité en outre l'économie verte
est particulièrement dynamique 263
milliards de dollars ont été investis
dans les énergies renouveles à l'échelle
mondiale en 2011 somme en croissant de
6,5 % soit 4 points de plus que la
croissance mondiale toujours en 2011 les
énergies vertes ont contribué à 2 % du
PIB français le potentiel de création
d'emploi est réel ne serait-ce que dans
le secteur de la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments le véritable enjeu est
donc celui du financement de cette
transition écologique une réflexion sur
la fiscalité verte sera lancée à partir
du printemps 2013 comme cela rappelé
dans le cadre de la Table Ronde
financement de la transition et
fiscalité écologique de la conférence
environnementale l'objectif est de taxer
les comportements peluant coûteux en
terme de ressources pour les orienter
vers des comportements plus vertueux
toutefois le levier de la fiscalité ne
suffira pas il faudra que l'ensemble du
dispositif de financement de l'économie
finisse par intégrer cet objectif de
transition écologique à commencer par
ces opérateurs publics la mission
générale donnée à la BPI est de répondre
à ce risque d'assèchement de crédit aux
insuffisan de fonds propres qui
handicapent le développement des
entreprises à commencé par les PME et
les ETI elle rassemblera donc dans une
structure unique les activités de zoo du
FSI et de CDC entreprise fédérer ces
organismes et leur action dans le
contexte général actuel de crise
économique et financière app portera une
vraie valeur ajoutée le directeur
général de la CA Dépôts et Consignation
Monsieur Jean-Pierre jouillet soulignait
combien le fait de rassembler sous un
même toit les différentes institutions
de prêt et de prise de participation au
capital constituaient un progrès
considérable la BPI disposera d'une
capacité d'intervention conséquente
environ 42 milliards d'euros soit 20
milliards en prês 12 milliards en
garantie et 10 milliards en capacité
d'investissement en fonds propres ces 42
milliards devrai permettre de générer
par effet de levier plus de 100
milliards de
financement le projet de loi déposé à
l'Assemblée nationale était forcé de le
con constaté succens sur les objectif
assigné à la BPI il se contentait en
fait de modifier à la marge l'ordonnance
portant création d'OSO nos collègues
députés ont jugé nécessaire de compléter
ces objectifs et en particulier de
rappeler dès l'article 1er la vocation
de la BPI à mettre en œuvre la
transition écologique cet atout était
cet ajout était nécessaire et chacun
s'en félicitera cette ambition est
ensuite déclinée dans lesmission des
différentes instances de gouvernance de
la banque plusieurs amendements portés
notamment par la Commission de
développement durable de l'Assemblée
nationale ont permis d'inclure dans les
comités d'orientation nationale et
régionaux de la banque des personnalités
qualifiées en matière de développement
durable là encore c'est une bonne chose
je veux aussi souligner la
reconnaissance du rôle de l'ADEM dont
l'expertise est unanimement reconnue
cela devrait garantir que l'objectif de
la transition écologique ne sera pas
marginalisé dans les options de
financement retenues par
l'établissement le second aspect
important de ce projet de loi est sa
contribution au développement économique
régional si les dispositifs publics
actuels d'Aid au financement des
entreprises ont déjà une forte dimension
régionale celle-ci sera notoirement
renforcée par l'organisation de la
future
BPI les établissements financiers qui
doivent être regroupés au sein de la BPI
interviennent en effet au plus près du
terrain
OSEO est organisé en 22 directions
régionales et 12 délégations
territoriales les décisions de prayil
sont largement déconcentrées le fond
Stratégique d'Investissement un
fonctionnement plus centralisé mais son
comité d'orientation comporte des élus
CDC entreprise dispose de 14
implantations interrégionales via sa
filière FSI région et participe à 80
fonds 84 fonds régionaux de leur côté
les régions sont pour la plupart
engagées dans le soutien au PME en
association ou en complément de l'action
des opérateurs de l'État dans le cadre
de leur stratégie régionale de
développement économique elles se sont
doté de plusieurs instruments prêt sur
l'honneur fonds de garantie et Fonds
d'innovation qui peuvent être confiés en
gestion à auoseo fonds régionaux
d'investissement aide à l'exportation le
président de l'ARF Alain Rousset a
indiqué lors de son audition devant les
nos commissions réunies qu'il existait
plus de 800 dispositifs régionaux
l'implication des régions dans le
financement des entreprises est donc un
phénomène général même si les modalité
et l'importance de l'effort consenti
varie d'une région à l'autre la loi en
tire les conséquences en réservant une
place particulière aux régions dans la
gouvernance de la
BPI l'article 1er dispose en effet que
la BPI agit en appui des politiques
publiques conduites par l'État et
conduites par les régions en ce qui
concerne son conseil d'administration
l'article 3 prévoit que sur 15 membres
deux seront des représentants de la des
régions nommés par décret sur
proposition d'une association
représentative de l'ensemble des régions
la BPI est également dotée d'un comité
national d'orientation changer
d'exprimer un avis sur ses orientations
stratégiques sa doctrine d'intervention
et les modalités d'exercice de sa
mission d'intérêt général l'article 4 du
projet de loi initiale prévoyait que ce
comité de 23 membres comporterait deux
représentants des régions désignés par
une association représentative de
l'ensemble des régions l'Assemblée
nationale a porté ce chiffre à 3 il est
par ailleurs prévu que le président du
comité national d'orientation sera
choisi parmi ces trois représentants des
régions leur présence au comité d'
national d'orientation sera l'occasion
pour les régions d'expliquer de
promouvoir leurs politiques économiques
auprès des parlementaires des
partenaires sociaux et des personnalités
qualifiées qui le composent par ailleurs
l'article 4 prévoit également la mise en
place dans chaque région d'un comité
régional d'orientation chargé de
formuler un avis sur les modalités
d'exercice de la par la BPI de ses
missions au niveau régional et sur la
cohérence de ces orientation stratégique
avec la stratégie régionale de
développement économique ce comité
régional d'orientation de 25 membres
comportte deux représentants de la
région le projet de loi initial
prévoyait qu'il soit présidé par le
président du conseil régional mais ces
dispositions a été supprimé par la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
nationale votre commission du
développement durable a proposé comme la
Commission des finance de rétablir cette
présidence qui lui paraît plus conforme
au souhaits exprimés par les régions et
aux engagements pris par le gouvernement
à leur
égard au total vous l'aurez compris
c'est un avis positif que votre de
développement durable a émis sur ce
projet de loi elle souhaite que la BPI
soit la banque du renouveau de la
croissance française clairement tourné
vers l'accompagnement des secteurs à
fort potentiel de l'économie verte et
vers le soutien au tissu économique
régional je forme le vux que cette
nouvelle structure soit mise en place et
en ordre de fonctionnement le plus
rapidement possible dès les premiers
mois 2013 et que sa gestion soit
conduite dans un souci réel
d'exemplarité
merci merci mon cher collègue la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe Marini président
de la commission des
finances monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la formule utilisée par le
ministre porte-avion du pacte de
compétitivité me semble appeler quelques
commentaires c'est
vue de
l'extérieur ce porte-avion à fire allure
mais est-il doté des moteurs et de la
capacité opérationnelle
indispensable si l'on s'en
tient au propos
verbaux ou aux
formulations d'ailleurs très peu
normativ de l'article 1er de ce texte de
loi certes il n'y aurait que des éloges
à faire en vue de soutenir la croissance
durable l'emploi la compétitivité de
l'économie la banque favorise
l'innovation le développement
l'internationalisation la mutation la
transmission des entreprises en
contribuant à leur financement en prêt
et en fond
propres plus loin on apprend que la BPI
intervient notamment en soutien des
secteurs d'avenir investit de manière
avisée on serait tenté de dire
heureusement pour financer les projets
de long terme on apprend qu'elle a
vocation à mettre en œuvre la transition
écologique cher à certains de nos
collègues on apprend qu'elle favorise
une mobilisation de l'ensemble du
système bancaire sur les projets qu' qu
soutient et cetera et cetera nos
collègues députés manifestement ont
trouvé qu'il n'y avait pas encore assez
d'affichage de bonnes
intentions puisqu'ils ont inséré en
particulier le merveilleux article 3 B a
au terme duquel la future banque devra
prendre en compte les enjeux
environnementaux sociaux d'égalités
professionnelle et de gouvernance dans
ses pratiques ainsi que dans la
constitution et la gestion de son
portefeuille
d'engagement elle devra intégrer les
risques sociaux et environnementaux dans
sa gestion des risques et se rise sur le
gâteau elle devra tenir compte des
intérêts des parties prenantes entendu
comme l'ensemble de ceux qui participent
à sa vie économique et des acteurs de la
société civile influencé directement ou
indirectement par ses activités
on va même
jusqu'à étudier la mise en place d'un
comité de responsabilité sociale et
environnemental
indépendant ainsi mes chers collègues
tout ici est exemplaire exemplaire dans
l'emphase dans la nouvelle langue de
notre époque celle du développement
durable celle de toutes les bonnes
intentions et il s'y ajoute dans la
composition du conseil d'administration
et celle des différents comités
théodules
d'orientation tout l'affichage
souhaitable du politiquement correct on
pourrait presque en faire un
traité à présent mes chers collègues
tâchons de regarder derrière les
hyperboles les formules un peu
boursoufflé les
autocompliments
l'autocélébration ce qui qui nous est
proposé
certes à mon
sens il ne s'agit ici de rien d'autre
que d'assembler des choses qui existent
et qui au demeurant fonctionnent plutôt
bien c'est
Oso c'est le fond Stratégique
d'Investissement créé par le président
Sarko c'est CDC
entreprise et c'est un projet somme tout
très
similaire par rapport à celui dit de
banque de l'industrie dont on nous avait
parlé au tout début de l'année
2012 mais peut-être ce rapprochement ne
sera-t-il pas si simple peut-être
prend-on le risque de déstabiliser des
équipes des personnels qui au dememurant
obéissent à des statuts et bénéficient
de rémunération de régime divers
sans doute aussi faut-il être
attentif aux conditions de nouveaux
conflits d'intérêts entre la BPI
prêteuse et la BPI
investisseuse d'autant que si j'ai bien
compris le directeur général du holding
sera aussi le président directeur
général des
filiales à mon sens il faut très
précisément s'interroger comme
d'ailleurs l'a fait notre rapporteur
général sur la question des conditions
de refinancement de ce nouveau groupe ne
prend-on pas gratuitement le risque de
perturber les prêteurs et d'obtenir
moins moins bien qu'on obtient à elle
seule l'actuel
Oso qui a une signature
appréciée ne prend-on pas le risque
de faire payer cher en point de base à
la banque publique d'investissement et
donc à ses clients cet écran qui sera
constitué par l'établissement public
holding
entre les deux actionnaires état et
Caisse des Dépôts d'une part et
l'établissement public et
l'établissement de crédit opérationnel
d'autre part et si j'en crois la presse
économique monsieur le ministre le
directeur général pressenti lui-même a
émis des doutes et n'a pas paru
franchement enthousiaste devant le
schéma capitalistique que vous nous avez
décrit au-delà des structures derrière
l'écran de fumée toujours bienvenu des
belles formules il demeure une
réalité cette banque publique
d'investissement ce
porte-avion n'aura de capacité
opérationnelle qu'en fonction des moyens
qui lui seront apportés et des fonds
propres dont il pourra disposer or lors
de notre séance de commission votre
Ministre délégué Benoît amont ne nous
l'a pas caché dans le meilleur des cas
la banque ne peut espérer recevoir avant
fin
2014 c'est-à-dire dans 2 ans les fonds
propres souscrits par ces actionnaires
mais non libérés et ce qui était vrai
doséo demeure vrai de la banque publique
d'investissement j'oserais dire encore
plus vrai puisqu'on attend tout de ce
nouvel établissement or c'est à partir
me semble-t-il de ces fonds propres
souscrits non libérés que vous avez fait
vos calculs qui vous permettent de dire
de clamer que cette banque publique
d'investissement aurait une force de
frappe de 42 milliards d'euros je doute
fort qu'elle les a et mon doute est une
litote dès sa constitution en tout cas
dès le début de l'année 2013 or d'ici là
les entrepreneurs pour qui cette banque
est faite aont à subir monsieur le
ministre j'ai le regret de le dire les
effets eux bien réels de votre politique
et en particulier de votre politique
fiscale ils auront vu la déductibilité
de leur charg financière limité et pour
ceux qui savent réussir ils auront vu
les services fiscaux les rattraper
et les conduire à devoir acquitter une
imposition de plus de 60 % sur leur
plusvalue avant d'appliquer aux
personnes physiques un ISF sensiblement
alourdi et pas vraiment
plafonné regardons par conséquent mes
chers collègues la vérité la réalité en
face la réalité c'est que dans ce texte
même dont les premiers articles proclam
et l'on ne peut à la vérité que sen R
jou IR le bonheur bancaire intégral vous
nous demandez ensuite et c'est à
l'article 13
l'autorisation de valider une démarche
qui me semble pleine de menaces pour les
entreprise il s'agit de ce blancin que
vous sollicitez du Parlement pour
pouvoir rédiger des ordonnan afin de
tirer les conséquences dans notre droit
de façon anticipée et à mon avis
précipité d'une transposition
européenne qui intégrerait les normes
comptable de balle 3 or il me semble
monsieur le ministre que ceci est
vraiment tout à fait
prématuré d'autant plus que bien des
grands pays a commencé par les
États-Unis choisissent eux de
s'affranchir de ces nouvelles normes
pour un temps indéterminé or il est
certain que si on les applique et et si
en particulier nous les appliquons en
Europe avant les États-Unis de
nombreuses entreprises petites moyennes
intermédiaires et grandes bénéficieront
de moins de crédit de la part du système
bancaire mes chers collègues dans cette
phase de rigueur dans la gestion des
finances publiques il est évidemment
satisfaisant d'employer des belles
formules car cela ne coûte rien ne coûte
rien au budget de l'État en particulier
mais cela peut coûter me semble-t-il en
terme de nouvelles désillusions au sein
de notre tissu social et
économique à mon sens les
multinationales comme de très nombreuses
entreprises de nos régions de nos
territoires sont à actuellement
attentiste et pour ne pas parler de
celle qui serait
sensible au signes d'une fiscalité qui
leur semblerait excessive et qu'on le
veuille ou non euh notre pays en
particulier sous ce gouvernement est
loin d'avoir gagné en terme de
compétitivité et d'attractivité à mon
sens ce n'est pas ce projet de loi qui
fera oublier aux entrepreneurs petits et
grands les boulets fiscaux qui sont à
leurs pieds et qui vont continuer à être
collectionné de texte en texte depuis le
collectif budgétaire de cet été en
passant par la loi de financeces pour
2013 rejeté par le sén je formulerai
donc quelques propositions dans le débat
monsieur le ministre afin en
particulier de bien préciser que la
banque publique d'investissement ne sera
pas un facteur de dilusion voire de
démantellement de la Caisse des Dépôts
et Consignation il me semble que
l'intégrité de ce groupe fait partie du
pacte républicain est un élément solide
de notre politique économique et que
tout ce qui peut mettre en doute cette
intégrité ne va pas dans le bon sens de
la même manière il me semble que la
structure juridique que vous avez
choisie n'est pas la plus optimale la
plus souhaitable et pour l'ensemble de
ces raisons il est nécessaire monsieur
le ministre que nous ayons un débat sur
ces questions quoi qu'il en soit il me
semble que la abilité des parlementaires
est certes d'aller au bout du débat mais
en aucun cas de cautionner ce qui risque
de s'apparenter à une grande illusion
merci mes chers collègues de votre
attention merci monsieur le Président
dans la suite de la discussion générale
commune la parole est à Monsieur
Christian Bourquin pour le groupe
RDSE
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre Pierre
Moscovici mes chers
collègues pour traiter la crise nos
prédécesseurs au gouvernement nvec un
mot
austérité mon prédécesseur ici Monsieur
Marini a démontré qu'il était toujours
tenant de cette vision des
choses ce qui fait qu'il n'a pas très le
moral il nous l'a expliqué sur laavenir
nous nous pensons qu'il faut créer
toutes les conditions pour que le
système économique redémarre et donc
investir au maximum et pour investir il
faut
favoriser l'accès au moyen de
l'investissement d'ailleurs dans son
programme présidentiel c'est parmi ces
priorités que François Hollande a
inscrit la création de la Banque
publique d'investissement la BPI
priorité numéro 1 de ces 60
propositions il a alors décrit les
grandes lignes de ce qu'il considérait
comme une banque d'un type nouveau voué
à l'accompagnement de tous ces projets
qui en dépit de leur potentiel sont
restés Mornés faute de financement nous
savons ça a été dit ici je leur dit à
quel point les accords de bal 3 ont
rendu les acteurs bancaires encore plus
frileux encore plus frileux que
jamais le président de la République a
proposé alors candidat à la fondation
d'une banque soucieuse de participer à
l'élaboration d'un avenir meilleur en
restant attentif au développement de
l'économie sociale et solidaire ainsi
qu'à l'accompagnement de la conversion
écologique et énergétique de l'industrie
or les banque rechine à soutenir les
projets innovants c'est un constat
évident sur le territoire et plus encore
lorsque leur équilibre économique ne
peut être atteint qu'à moyen terme cette
banque à BPI cette banque se devrait
d'être ce devait d'être publique
publique pour rompre avec la logique de
recherche de la rentabilité financière
maximale et immédiate des banques
classiques c'est effectivement le seul
moyen efficace d'organiser la bonne
irrigation du tissu entrepreneurial
territorial
local cette promesse faite pendant la
campagne présidentielle et ses esquis se
trouvent leur traduction concrète dans
les deux textes que nous examinons
aujourd'hui le premier porte le projet
même de la création de la Banque
publique d'investissement sur les fonds
baptismaux le second de valeur organique
permet au Parlement de contrôler les
nominations à sa tête dans les travaux
préparatoires menés par l'exécutifs le
rôle incontournable des régions a été
reconnu quoi de plus naturel en effet
que de se tourner vers les conseils
régionaux lorsqu'il est question de
développement économique alors Monsieur
le Ministre allons-y franchement sur cet
outil de l'avenir sur cet outil de la
croissance l'histoire politique récente
plaide en 82 le développement économique
local est devenu l'un des principaux
domaines d'intervention ce rôle a été
confirmé par la loi de 2004 sur les
libertés et responsabilités locales qui
par la volonté du Sénat a confié à
chaque région le soin de coordonné sur
son territoire l'ensemble des actions de
développement économique des
collectivités territoriales et de leur
groupement alors sous réserve bien
entendu et c'est toujours d'actualité du
respect des missions incombant à l'état
évidemment depuis lors les régions ont
gagné un savoir-faire et en créativité
c'est un constat j'en tiens pour preuve
leur participation un dispositif pilote
en matière de développement des PME et T
PEE mis sur pied à l'initiative de la
Commission européenne de la la Banque
européenne d'investissement la BEI et du
Fond Européen d'Investissement le FEI ce
dispositif consiste à une boîte à outil
d'ingénierie financière la convention de
financement
Jérémie le Conseil Régional du langodoc
Rousillon a mis sur pied dès 2008 ce
programme destiné à offrir aux petites
et moyennes entreprises de nouvelles
ressources financières à chaque stade de
leur vie il ne s'agissait pas d'une aide
classique accordée sous forme de
subvention mais bien de ce qui
préfigurait déjà les aides de demain je
veux parler de cette ingénierie
financière dont nous devons nous doter
des aides composées de prêt de prise de
participation ou encore de garantie
répondant à une logique de recyclage des
fonds publics je sais à quel point
monsieur le ministre cette expérience a
certainement retenu toute votre
attention dans la préparation du projet
de loi mais permettez-moi aussi aussi et
également de saluer à vos côtés la
volonté de votre Ministre délégué en
charge du commerce extérieur de mettre
la BPI au service des PME et entreprises
de taille intermédiaire
exportatrices en pourvoyant notamment
leur besoin de trésorerie entre autres
ce volet international essentiel aussi
de la banque ne figurait pas dans le
fameux je dis bien fameux rapport par an
et cela
manquait cette priorité ciblé sera porté
par tous soyez-en convaincus certes par
le gouvernement mais aussi par les
régions si l'on considère en effet le
succès à l'exportation de notre voisin
allemand en ces temps de crise lequel se
fonde sur le tissu dynamique des ETI on
comprend que le soutien aux PME est
indispensable non seulement parce
qu'elles sont génératrices d'emplois et
qu'elle constiue un enjeu majeur en
matière de maillage territorial mais
aussi car elles ont un rôle fort à jouer
dans le cadre
du redressement de notre balance
commerciale faut-il rappeler les 70
milliards de déficit en matière de
soutien au PME nous avons pris beaucoup
beaucoup de retard nous disposons de
9000 entreprises exportatrices à ce jour
en France soit qu fois moins qu'en
Allemagne rien qu'à ce chiffre on
comprend qu'il est urgent d'agir cela
commence par la création des outils
avant de le l'argent à qui prêter
l'argent créons ces
entreprises poussons-les créons ces
outils adaptés et rapidement il faudra
veiller à ce que les crédits nécessaires
soient dégagés pour pouvoir les
utiliser enfin je voudrais le dire ici
je me réjouis des améliorations d'ors
déjà apporté au texte par la commission
des finances du Sénat lors de la lecture
du texte par no par nos collègues
députés quelques incohérences ont été
introduit dans sa rédaction
je pense notamment à l'éviction
malencontreuse des présidents des
Conseils Régionaux de la présidence des
comités d'orientation régionaux de la
BPI
l'accident va être
réparé comme en témoigne la nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 4 du texte issu
des travaux de la commission c'est bien
que la maison qui représente la
République des élus locaux et des
territoires
rétablissent cette portée
elle a fait son travail et un travail
qui sera utile à
l'avenir concernant la composition des
conseil régionaux d'orientation j'ai
bien noté qu'un amendement proposé par
le rapporteur Bourquin
monomonyme par la commission des
affaires économiques envisager sa
modification avec pour objectif de
donner plus de poids au représent à la
représentation
régionale pour ma part j'ai une autre
proposition à faire qui consiste à
favoriser l'adaptation de ces conseils
d'orientation à la spécificité de chaque
territoire la diversité des territoires
doit
s'exprimer l'unité de la République
n'est pas menacée la cohérence de la
banque n'est pas pour autant troublé ou
n'en serait pas pour autant troublé à
l'occasion de la lecture de l'article 4
du texte je suis sûr que nous aurons
certainement un débat intéressant sur ce
sujet et je voulais donner rendez-vous
pour conclure monsieur le ministre je
souhaitais vous
interroger je souhaitais vous interroger
sur un point du texte qui ne relève pas
de la loi il s'agit de la question de la
présence des régions dans les comités
d'engagement de la BPI autrement dit
d'un aspect intégrant la doctrine
d'action de la banque il me paraît
toutefois fondamental pour la poursuite
même de ce beau projet auquel j'ai noté
monsieur Marini croit surtout pas que et
pour les espoirs qu'il porte qu'il
puisse s'incarner que la la composition
des comités d'engagement ne délaisse pas
la représentation régionale monsieur le
ministre qu'en pensez-vous vous avez
rien dit là-dessus c'est du
développement économique de proximité
qu'il
s'agit qu'en pensez-vous tout à l'heure
quand vous avez parlé floré ce texte ce
ce propos vous avez dit il faut que les
choses soient claires vous m'avez
surpris pourquoi serait pas clair avec
la présence des régions vous m'avez
chagriné même au moment où attend tous
une énorme décentralisation je sais pas
comment elle viendra mais vous devez en
savoir quelque chose alors qu'en
pensez-vous de tout cela je me permets
de vous questionner
merci merci mon cher collègue la parole
est à Jean-Vincent Placé pour le groupe
écologie
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues la France connaît une
situation économique difficile notamment
en terme de politique industrielle si
cette situation est en partie imputable
à la crise est aussi le fruit de la
gestion de du gouvernement précédent en
effet en 10ant nous avons perdu 750000
emplois je vois que c laa Suiss c'était
très positif c'était notamment l'un des
objectifs qui est rempli comme
d'habitude nous avons donc perdu non
monsieur delat nous avons perdu 750000
emplois dans l'industrie et pas moins de
350000 en 5 ans depuis 2007 des choix
stratégiques auraient dû être fait
réalisés bien en amant pour répondre aux
enjeux de l'industrie rien na été fait
nous en subissons aujourd'hui les
conséquences c'est une réalité
extrêmement simple parce qu'elle est
factuelle et mathématique il n'est
jamais trop tard pour agir et je me
réjouis que le gouvernement avec son
premier ministre et avec ici le ministre
de l'Économie pierre moscoviss donne
naissance à cette grande initiative la
banque publique d'investissement la BPI
qui ça a été rappelé la première
proposition du Président de la
République François Hollande nous les
écologistes nous demandons cela depuis
longtemps nous croyons en effet comme la
majorité
gouvernementale et sénatoriale à la
force de la puissance publique pour
actionner les leviers nécessaires à
invvestissement dans les filières
d'avenir répondant ainsi au défi de la
compétitivité notamment la compétitivité
hors coût du renouvellement de
l'industrie de la transition écologique
de
l'économie merci chers collègues
président de la République François
Hollande a dit le gouvernement le fait
je tiens à saluer le travail de
coélaboration de la loi qui a été mis en
œuvre déjà grâce aux commissions de
l'Assemblée nationale ça a été rappelé
par nos deux rapporteurs le texte a été
enrichi cette version a également été
amélioré en commission des finances au
Sénat et les débats de la commission
développement durable ont été
particulièrement utiles elle peut je
pense l'être encore d'avantage grâce à
nos débats et nos amendements et je vois
le président Bourquin qui a rappelé lui
le travail des présidents de région et
il a bien raison également lorsque le
gouvernement est attentif c'est
l'inconvénient d'en citer quelques-uns
on commence évidemment aller au-delà
lorsque le gouvernement est attentif et
ouvert aux propositions de sa majorité
je soulligne avec plaisir c'est à partir
d'un texte de loi respectueux de la
parité des enjeux écologiques des PME et
des régions que nous allons discuter je
crois que nous partons déjà d'un bon
texte d'une bonne base le gouvernement a
bien pris la mesure du défi économique
industriel et il y met les moyens avec
une capacité d'investissement de 40
milliards à 70 milliards d'euros nous
pouvons raisonnablement espérer financer
de beaux projets y compris avec un effet
de levier qui pourrait nous mener
au-delà encore comme vous monsieur le
ministre Pierre moscovissi je crois
qu'il faut agir vite et cette réactivité
vous honore en effet il y a urgence car
pour 10,3 % de personnes en France c'est
la galère du chômage l'anxiété de la
précarité la BPI concerne aussi l'emploi
on n'en parle pas suffisamment à cet
égard il est d'ailleurs naturel que le
représentant des salariés la société
civile soit présent dans les instances
de gouvernance même si je l'ai dit mais
d'autres collègues le diront également
nous pensons que le Conseil économique
social et environnemental ainsi que la
Banque de France pour son expertise
doivent être davantage associé la BPI ce
n'est pas qu'un nouvel organisme
bancaire de plus comme ça pu être dit
qui s'ajoute et regroupe tous les autres
non la BPI c'est une nouvelle
institution nationale éthique
stratégique et ancré dans le réel
économie réelle ce sont notamment les
TPE les PME qui éprouvent tant de
difficultés à se financer auprès des
banques qui ne s'y retrouvent plus entre
tous les acteurs financiers qui ne sont
pas accompagnés dans leur projets qui
doivent résister dans des délais de
gestion bien trop longs la réalité c'est
qu'elles sont le plus grand employeur de
France et qu'elles n'arrive plus ni à
préserver ni à créer d'emploi alors oui
il faut agir maintenant mais la rapidité
d'action ne doit pas s'opérer qu'au
gouvernement et au Parlement en votant
cette loi elle doit surtout s'appliquer
après au moment de la gestion des
dossiers de financement des entreprises
la BPI que nous souhaitons c'est une
banque innovante qui réponde aux
défaillance du système bancaire
classique et qui prend des risques
stratégiques en faveur de projets
d'avenir et non pas donc évidemment
seulement dans une logique comptable et
financière la BPI pour répondre
véritablement aux problèmes concrets des
entrepreneurs doit constituer
effectivement ce guichet unique surtout
au niveau régional ça a été dit et ainsi
mettre fin un système complètement
illisible qui multiplie les organismes
les interlocuteurs et les démarches
administratives ce qui a permis
d'ailleurs tous les excès le président
Marini parlait de du FSI oui l'outil est
intéressant on a pu voir aussi à quelle
destination cela avait pu aller y
compris dans des interventions qui
étaient pas du tout nécessaire qui on
répondait pas du tout et vous le savez
monsieur le Président Marini aux
orientations stratégiques de
départ oui oui oui oui oui je ne cite
pas pour ne pas être désagréable enfin
pour être efficace la BPI ne peut faire
l'économie de s'intégrer dans les
territoires ce sont les régions qui
mieux que quiconque connaissent les
enjeux du tché économique local la BPI
ne peut se contenter d'être en effet un
organisme de plus qui prend les
décisions d'en haut déconnecté du
terrain c'est pourquoi les conseils
régionaux doivent être pleinement
associé ainsi d'ailleurs que les
chambres de commerce et d'industrie dont
je soulligne toujours le caractère
solide et proche des réalités leurs
expertises sont un véritable atout tout
comme celle des agence spécialisé
régionale qui travaille quotidiennement
avec les acteurs économiques ce sont ces
institutions locales qui connaissent
vraiment les PME qui les conseills les
accompagneent dans leur projet la prise
de décision soit s'appu doit s'appuyer
sur ces compétences et cette
connaissance fine du territoire c'est le
sens de l'un de nos
amendements par ailleurs la banque
publique d'investissement par son
caractère national pourra contribuer à
la réduction des inégalités
territoriales c'est aussi une de ses
missions essentiel à cet
égard il me semble inconcevable que la
BPI exclut ou n'exclut pas d'ailleurs
mais ne l'indique pas expressément dans
le texte les zones rurales et les
outresmèes de son champ d'action je
crois que c'est une préoccupation
importante des collègues de notre haute
assemblée mais je crois que la qualité
première la BPI au-delà de tout ce que
je viens de dire c'est d'être au service
d'un état stratège en plus du soutien à
l'emploi la compétitivité l' innovation
la conversion numérique l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui sont des
secteurs essentiels je crois que la
référence explicite à la transition
écologique et énergétique est
primordiable cela éé dit par notre
rapporteur à DOA la conférence sur le
climat n'a clairement pas été à la
hauteur en France démontrons que nous
prenons la mesure des enjeux écologiques
faisons de la PPI une institution
exemplaire comme le propose Pierre
Moscovici il y a là un impératif
environnemental nous le savons les
émissions de CO2 sont de plus de 50
Gigaton par an alors qu'il faudrait se
trouver aux alentours de 44 Gigaton en
2020 selon le dernier rapport du
Programme des Nations Unies pour
l'Environnement il y a aussi un
impéactif social et économique nous
devons créer de l'emploi et de
l'activité en France la transition
écologique de la France de l'économie
est une chance pour permettre au
secteurs industriel et productif de se
redresser
réellement les énergies renouvelables
les transport l'efficacité énergétique
dans les bâtiments pour ne citer que ces
exemples représentent des centaines de
milliers d'emplois la BPI doit faire
confiance aux filières d'avenir et
innovante les projets d'économie
circulaire de fonctionnalité la
production de nouveaux matériaux sont
également des pistes sérieuses pour une
économie redynamisée et respectueuse de
l'environnement les écologistes nous
pensons qu'il y a une véritable
opportunité pour l'état de répondre de
façon stratégique aux difficultés
présentes tout en préparant l'avenir
nous proposerons donc un amendement pour
affirmer que la transition écologique
énergétique est un objectif à part
entière de la PPI confortant
l'amendement dont nous avons parlé issu
des travaux de nos collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale nous souhaitons
également qu'un rapport statistique soit
remis chaque année afin de pouvoir
apprécier les progrès de la banque en la
matière mais également pour renforcer la
transparence et le contrôle du Parlement
la confiance n'exclut pas le contrôle on
on le sait c'est une devise bien connu
j'aimerais que monsieur le ministre nous
détaille dans la discussion je sais
qu'il le fera les modalités
d'application l'institution financière
va-t-elle se doter de barè de critères
sociaux et environnementaux
d'indicateurs pour respecter ses
engagements l'écologie ne peut pas une
fois de plus se contenter d'être
inscrite comme un principe plébiscité
mais jamais concrétisé mais je sais que
ce n'est pas la volonté du gouvernement
certes la BPI ne peut pas elle seule
permettre la transition écologique de
l'économie mais elle peut y contribuer
le financement est tout de même un outil
indispensable de cette mutation que nous
appelons nos vœux et n'est pas
suffisante et j'attire l'attention du
gouvernement sur la nécessité pour les
entreprises de mettre en œuvre un signal
prix significatif pas que les acteurs
qui polluent soit pénalisé
financièrement par rapport à ceux qui
font des efforts ou alors ceux qui font
des efforts et des bonus voilà cette
vision qu'on doit avoir de positif pour
qu'il y a un intérêt rationnel à
modifier les comportements productifs
c'est ainsi en imposant sûrement des
normes queon pousse un secteur à se
renouveler nous souhaitons donc unee
taxe carbone la contribution énergie
climat du programme du président de la
République par exemple soit mise en
œuvre rapidement ce n'est pas tout les
entreprises ont également besoin de
lisibilité de stabilité les
réglementations mériteraient d'être
définis pour le quinquena et de ne plus
changer je crois que c'est extrêmement
important quand on voit les soucis qu'on
aus PME PMI par rapport au changement
législatifs et réglementaires et leur
inquiétude à chaque PLF c'est un sujet
extrêmement sérieux pour permettre à nos
entreprises d'avoir une visibilité sur
le long terme pour prévoir leurs
investissements je recevais l'autre jour
un directeur général une entreprise
éolienne important qui me disait encore
et même moi je ne suis pas parmi ceux
qui dénigre le pays en disant c'est
toujours mieux ailleurs mais tout de
même il m'a démontré qu'il avait des
éoliennes en Allemagne qu'il faisait en
8 ans et en 2 ans et que malheureusement
chez nous il les faisait en 8 ans et ça
c'est vraiment une façon de faire qu'il
faut absolument changer pour ne pas
décourager nous croyons vous le savez
les écologistes en l'économie social et
solidaire nous nous félicitons qu'une
partie des affectations lui soit dessiné
même si cela pu cel pu être plus
significatif pour conclure la banque
publique d'investissement est pour nous
une très bonne initiative vous l'aurez
entendu elle apportera plus de nouvelles
capacités d'investissement de la
lisibilité aux entreprises pour
accompagner les projets dont la France a
besoin notamment en matière écologique
le gouvernement a cherché à établir là
une gouvernance purielle paritaire
équilibré aussi le groupe écologiste
soutient ce projet de loi relatif à la
création de la BPI nous aurons
l'occasion de vous présenter quelques
amendements qui ont vocation à apporter
davantage au débat et dont j'espère
qu'il y aura à une certaine acceptation
de votre part vous l'aurez compris quand
nous sommes insatisfaits nous avons une
certaine capacité à le dire mais quand
nous sommes satisfaits nous avons tout à
la fois cette capacité à le dire car
c'est important dans notre famille
politique dans notre majorité d'être
capable d'être tout à la fois dans les
la franchise et parfois aussi dans la
Résistance parce que on sait depuis bien
longtemps que on ne s'appuie que sur ce
qui résiste de temps en temps merci à
vous mes chers collègues merci monsieur
le Président la parole est à monsieur
Éric Boquet pour le groupe
CRC bien monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre mes chers
collègues premier des 60 engagements du
candidat François Hollande pour
l'élection présidentielle du printemps
dernier la banque publique
d'investissement pourrait être décriée
par principe comme porté au nu selon le
côté que l'on occupe dans cet hémicycle
mais nous avons l'impression qu'il est
bien plus utile de nous dégager des a
priori et d'aborder ce projet de la de
loi comme il comme ce qu'il est
c'estàdire un chantier ouvert un ouvrage
dont il importe que nous regardions
comment il est fait à quoi il peut
servir et comment nous pouvons en faire
l'outil d'un nouveau type de
développement
économique au nom des parlementaires du
groupe CRC attaché par principe à ce qui
peut apporter un plus à la société
française à ce qui peut répondre aux
attentes populaires en terme d'emploi de
réduction des inégalités sociales et de
celles du développement qui vont souvent
de per d'ailleurs et opposer à tout ce
qui éloigne les Françaises et les
Français de la véritable égalité je suis
donc chargé de vous donner notre
sentiment sur ce nouvel l'instrument
financier c'est une évidence de rappeler
sans que l'EN souffre sans doute la
fierté des auteurs du projet de loi que
la banque publique d'investissement est
sans doute bien autre chose a priori
qu'une sorte de revanche sur un passé
récent qui avait vu le gouvernement de
monsieur de Villepin créé aux eo sur la
base de la fusion de la banque de
développement des PME et de l'Agence
nationale pour la valorisation de la
recherche et le président Sarkozi
pousser les feux d'un fond souverain à
la française appelé fond stratégique
d'investissement on notera aussi qu'Oseo
avait en 2008 capté les activités de
l'agence pour l'innovation industrielle
créé presque en même temps en même temps
que l'établissement public lui-même par
le gouvernement de Monsieur
deVillepin cela ne change au fond pas
grand-chose au sujet qui nous préoccupe
sinon que trois structures pas tout à
fait identique pas tout à fait pourvu du
même bilan vont être appelés à
travailler ensemble sous le même chapeau
à savoir la
BPI mais bien évidemment si l'on
pourrait presque se satisfaire de la
logique qu'il pourrait y voir à faire
travailler ensemble des organismes
visant concrètement les mêmes objectifs
on ne peut nous semble-t-il se contenter
de voir monter en charge une banque
appelons-la ainsi qui ne fera rien de
plus que de regrouper les forces et les
capacités existantes
j'entends bien si l'on s'arrête au mot
causeéo je cite l'ordonnance de 2005 a
pour objet de premièrement promouvoir et
soutenir l'innovation notamment
technologique ainsi que contribuer au
transfert de technologie et de favoriser
le développement et le financement des
petites et moyennes entreprises fin de
citation et que de leur côté les
objectifs du FSI sont rappelés dans sa
doctrine d'investissement d'abord le
développement des petites et moyennes
entreprises de croissance pour lesqueles
il participe au financement en fond
propre via le programme France
investissement valeur d'entreprise
inférieure à 100 million d'euros 2 les
entreprises de taille moyenne valeur
d'entreprise comprise entre 100 millions
et 2 milliards d'euros qui dispose d'un
potentiel de création de valeur
notamment parce qu'elle maise des
technologies innovantes ou peuvent bâtir
des positions de leader pour lesquelles
ils jouent un rôle de catalyseur de
développement et d'innovation troè point
des entreprises de taille moyenne
présentes sur des secteurs en phase de
mutation qui parce que leurs
fondamentaux notamment techniques humain
ou produits sont sains peuvent émerger
comme acteur de référence de leur
segment par son intervention en fond
propre le FSI joue alors le rôle
d'accélérateur des redéploiements
industriels fin de
citation on on aura vu ainsi les points
communs ce ne sont manifestement pas les
seuls dont nous aurons un débattre ici
entre les interventions de l'un et de
l'autre des établissements appelés à
travailler ensemble mais il nous faut
ramener clairement la BPI à la source
même qui l'a inspiré à savoir le modèle
allemand celui de la kfv Credit einstal
F ver of Bao Banken group ou
établissement de crédit pour la
reconstruction structure bancaire hérité
de l'après-gerre chacun s'en souvient et
qui a largement financé à partir des
fonds du plan Marshal puis de de ses
retours de fonds et de ressources
sollicité ensuite auprès de la
Bundesbank et désormais des marchés
financiers le développement de
l'économie selon le modèle Renant acteur
majeur du redressement économique de
l'Allemagne fédérale l'établissement
dispose aujourd'hui d'une force de
frappe proche de 500 milliards d'euros
et certains analystes évoquent même le
fait qu'il est en situation parfois de
répondre aux fin de mois délicate de la
Banque centrale européenne il faut dire
que les deux institutions sont
domiciliées dans la même ville à savoir
l'industrieuse et commerçantes cité de
Francfort sur le Main le champ
d'intervention de l'établissement
d'abord wouest allemand et fédéral est
particulièrement large si nous voulions
assurer la symétrie parfaite entre la
BPI et son grand équivalent allemand
nous pourrions presque faire adopter
tout amendement reprenant exactement
l'une des missions assurées par
l'établissement qui va de la trésorerie
des PME à la coopération internationale
en passant par les investissements en
énergie renouvelable l'amélioration de
l'habitat la réalisation
d'infrastructures communales
ou les bourses d'études mais il
manquerait sans doute
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire que
l'antériorité de l'établissement
allemand lui ouvre aujourd'hui un bilan
d'un volume particulièrement important
je l'ai dit 500 milliards d'euros et que
la loi lui donne une capacité de lever
de ressources à tous les niveaux et en
tout lieu très importante il est évident
que lorsque le capital de
l'établissement est détenu à 80 % par
l'État fédéral et 20 % par les lenders
cela doit aider pour ouvrir les portes
la garantie de l'État étant sollicitée
en cas de défaut à noter que la kfv
dégage cet an dernier un bénéfice net
supérieur aux milliards d'euros signe
d'une gestion plutôt saine de ses
propres engagements et signe évident
d'un produit net bancaire dont elle n'a
en tout état de cause pas l'impérieux
besoin pour être tout à fait clair il
est évident que ce qui fait aussi la
force de l'établissement allemand c'est
son recours à la création monétaire
autant que ses retours de fonds et ou
surinvestissement il importe donc que la
nouvelle structure nous allons créer
avec ce projet de loi soit en situation
d'émettre des titres de créance
bénéficiant en cela de la qualité de la
signature de l'État français actionnaire
de référence et de celle de la caise des
Dépôts et Consignation dont les qualités
et la réputation ne sont plus à établir
près de de siècles après la création du
dit établissement que la BPI a la
qualité d'établissement de crédit quand
bien même elle confirer telle mission ou
telle intervention spécifique à une
filiale dédiée par la suite est une
nécessité
certains nous diront qu'oo est assez
doué en la matière pour lever sur les
marchés financiers les ressources dont
il a besoin pour son intervention de
même que la CDC a suffisamment
d'expérience en matière de création de
véhicules porteurs d'épares financières
et de fonds dédiés pour que cela fasse
le compte mais il importe à notre avis
que la BPI soit effectivement dotée de
la qualité d'établissement de crédit
parce qu'elle pourra dès lors assurer
son refinancement auprès de la Banque
centrale européenne dont le tau
directeur actuelle 0,75 % historiquement
bas demeure le meilleur argument pour
assurer autant que faire ce peut la
liquidité des marchés financiers et
ainsi alléger le loyer de l'argent dans
un contexte récessif malheureusement
pressenti pour 2013 plus la BPI sera en
situation d'intervenir auprès des
entreprises en leur proposant le
meilleur service c'est-à-dire assorti de
la charge d'intérêt la plus faible plus
nous serons en mesure de créer les
conditions nous permettant de sortir à
la fois du piège de la la staflation et
de celui du gaspillage des potentiels de
croissance la BPI ne deviendra pas même
si nous devons réfléchir à ce sujet un
acteur majeur du financement des
entreprises et de l'économie si elle
demeure cantonnée à la distribution de
prêts au demeurant plus risqué que ceux
accordés par les établissements de
crédit ordinaires adossés à des titres
et part d'entreprises publiques des
participations minoritaires dans
certaines entreprises privées
susceptibles d'être liquidé et
l'affectation des surplus éventuels de
fonds d'épargne
même l'existence d'une ressource fiscale
dédiée comme nous pouvons le voir en
d'autres domaines avec le 1 % logement
ou les fonds de la formation
professionnel ne saurait suffire à
l'essentiel la BPI ne peut agir
durablement et valablement que doté
comme n'importe quel autre banque du
pouvoir de création monétaire et il faut
notamment le faire de par la nature même
de l'intervention de l'établissement et
de ses filial nous laisserons à son
auteur le jugement péremptoire sur le
fait que la BPI n'a pas à être cré et
pour aider entre guillemets les canards
boiteux pour revenir à l'essentiel nous
avons dans notre pays si l'on en croit
les éléments en notre possession plus ou
moins 3,4 million d'entreprises de toute
taille de tout type de la plus petite à
la plus grande la majorité de cellees-ci
sont des sociétés capitaux dont une
grande majorité des TPE PME et ETI le
nombre des entreprises ne comptant aucun
salarié en général entreprise
individuelle et de plus de 2,23 millions
soit plus de so 65 % de nos entités les
entreprises comptant de 1 à 9 salariés
sont près d'un million et constituent
donc près de 29 % de l'ensemble de nos
entreprises nous avons donc en France un
ensemble d'un peu moins de 200000
entreprises dont les effectif salariés
excède le seuil de 10 salariés donc 95 %
compte en fait moins de 250 salariés et
constittu donc le cœur de cible de
l'action de la BPI la BPI est donc faite
pour nos 190000 PME de 10 à 249 salariés
et pour une partie du millions
d'entreprises plus petites qui peuvent
gagner en efficacité en production et en
création d'emplois pour peu qu'on leur
apporte un soutien efficient dans tous
les territoires de notre pays c'est une
dimension essentielle qu'il soit urbain
ou ruraux c'est une question d'équilibre
République ajoutons-y peut-être une
partie des 4 à 4500 entreprises comptant
entre 250 et un millier de salariés et
nous aurons ainsi le compte je sais bien
que la loi de modernisation de
l'économie place les entreprises de
taille intermédiaire sous la borne des
5000 salariés et celle des 2 milliards
d'euros de chiffres d'affaires mais cela
ne change pas grand-chose à la
démonstration le projet de loi établit
pour le moins une évidence ce n'est pas
forcément l'absence de fonds propre qui
crée une difficulté au développement de
nos entreprises mais bel et bien
d'inégalité d'accès au crédit bancaire
un crédit bancaire rare et cher voilà ce
qui consomme plus sûrement les fonds
propres de n'importe quelle entreprise
de production de biens et de service que
n'importe quelle cotisation sociale ou
juste rémunération du travail nous
devons clairement nous fixer un objectif
avec cette loi sur la BPI faire de
l'établissement un nouveau modèle
bancaire pour un nouveau type de crédit
réduisant l'obstacle principal à la
compétitivité et au développement de
notre industrie c'est-à-dire la
préemption des coûts du crédit sur la
valeur ajoutée et la richesse
produite ce texte s'il est mené jusqu'où
il doit aller et si la BPI joue le rôle
qu'il convient de donné peut nous
prouver une fois de plus une fois encore
que l'arme de la fiscalité n'est pas la
seule qui puisse modifier les données de
la situation économique et sociale dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons et qu'une
affectation économe de l'argent public
que peut coûter la garantie accordée par
l'État aux engagements de la BPI face
aux milliards d'euros que nous que nous
consacrons déjà à alléger les impôts et
les cotisations sociales prétendument au
nom de l'emploi intervenant dans les
circuits financiers eux-mêmes est
peut-être la meilleure solution que nous
puissions trouver une autre vertu
pourrait d'ailleurs être trouvée à une
BPI jouant pleinement son rôle celle
d'amener l'ensemble des acteur du monde
bancaire à reconsidérer leur stratégie
d'engagement de fond nonobstant ce que
nous pouvons attendre de la prochaine
discussion sur la réforme bancaire et
financière tel qu'elle s'esquisse pour
le moment avec la séparation des
activités de crédit et des activités
pour compte propre avec la loi de
modernisation de l'économie les acteurs
du milieu du milieu bancaire ont comme
chacun sa puis faire usage aux
ressources nouvelles celles tirées de
l'épargne populaire relativement peu
coûteuse et qui leur permis d'adosser
certaines opérations juteuses et
d'amortir certaines pertes subies par
ailleurs dans le tourbillon de la crise
financière de 2008 si la BPI monte
rapidement en puissance dans le paysage
bancaire de notre pays et joue le rôle
que peut jouer la kfv en Allemagne nul
doute que nous pourrons aussi constater
une évolution positive sur les taux
d'intérêt avec toutes les conséquences
que cela implique bien sûr c'est dans
cet esprit constructif lucide et
responsable que les parlementaires du
groupe CRC abordent l'examen de ce
projet de loi nous avons pour notre part
aussi déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements visant à tirer parti de
l'ensemble du potentiel transformateur
du texte pour mieux relier création
monétaire et création de richesse et
répondre aux objectifs généraux et
généreux qu'on semble vouloir assigner à
cette banque publique d'investissement
la réforme du crédit étant l'un des
éléments clés de la réussite du change
il ne pouvait en être autrement je vous
remercie de votre
attention merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur em de montescue
pour le groupe UD
IUC monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nos
entreprises souffrent de trois problèmes
majeurs l'atrophie de notre tissu
économique
intermédiaire une spécialisation
industrielle tournée essentiellement
vers les grandes
entreprises un climat fiscal et
financier anchiogène pour les
entreprises à fort potentiel de
développement mais celui qui surpasse
tous les autres est le
financement votre réponse s'appelle la
BPI pourquoi pas
le mal essentiel qui frappe notre tissu
économique industriel tient à la très
faible marge et aux capacités
d'investissement insuffisant de nos
entreprises depuis 30
ans le taux de marge français de 28 %
soit près de 10 points en dessous de la
moyenne européenne avec pour conséquence
annexe mais majeur notre déficit
commercial en effet les faibles marges
et la FA de la trésorerie des PME sont
un frein à leur développement et donc à
l'exportation le matraquage fiscal
aggrave cette situation et peine à créer
un climat favorable au développement et
à la croissance des entreprises la BPI
dont le rôle est de faire face à la
faiblesse de trésorerie des PME aurait
moins de nécessité d'être sans cette
fiscalité
handicapante terriblement la trésor de
nos
entreprises considérez l'Allemagne qui a
fait de sa fiscalité patrimoniale la
source vive de mittle stand le dynamique
tissu des PME
ETI votre projet de loi a pour but
d'améliorer l'accession des PME des ETI
un système de financement public tourné
principalement vers le long terme c'est
un besoin vital pour nos entreprises je
le reconnais et le souligne même à
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur le
ministre vous avez déclaré que vous
aviez la conviction que ce texte portera
une cause qui peut nous rassembler tous
sur tous les bancs celle du financement
de l'investissement celle de la
compétitivité de l'économie celle du
développement des entreprises et de nos
territoires bref celle du redressement
de notre pays ce soit est aussi le nôtre
comment ne pas adhérer aux objectif de
la banque publique d'investissement
innovation développement
internationalisation des entreprises
simplification par un guichet unique
reconnaissance du rôle économique des
régions vous présentez la BPI comme la
banque des entreprise de croissance du
tissu économique de nos territoirees de
la stratégie industrielle un outil
offensif et performant au service de la
croissance et de l'emploi les emplois
d'avenir a destination des seules
collectivités des associations
n'andqueront pas le chômage leur utilité
est exclusivement sociale et va à
l'encontre de votre objectif de baisse
du nombre des fonctionnaires c'est grâce
aux entreprises et à l'initiative privée
que la France sortira de l'ornière et
non pas grâce à des emplois publics déjà
trop nombreux l'économie générale de la
BPI est simple vous l'avez rappelé il
s'agit de rappeler au de rapprocher au
eo la branche entreprise de la caisse de
dépôts et le FSI en une structure unique
de la mouture d'oséon néanmoins les
trois établissements existants ont
chacun leur spécificités AUO la banque
des PME a pour fonction l'aide à
l'innovation la garantie des concours
bancaires et des investisseurs en fonds
propres et le financement en partenariat
avec des correspondants en région le
fond Stratégique d'Investissement répond
aux besoins de en fond propres
d'entreprisees porteuses de croissance
et de compétitivité pour l'économie
française par une participation
minoritaire en capital CD entreprisees
participent au soutien des entreprises
de longue date pour le développement
industriel de notre pays je rappelle ces
spécificités pour m'interroger sur leur
fongibilité le groupe udi vous
questionne sur plusieurs points vaut-il
mieux créer une seule gros structure ou
garder les trois qui existent et qui
fonctionnent votre formule disposet-elle
de plus de souplesse de réactivité pour
répondre aux besoins des entreprises une
grosse structure aura-t-elle une force
de frappe plus grande par l'addition des
trois capacités financières ou au
contraire sera-t-elle moins
réactive je crains que toutes ces
missions que vous attribuez à cette
banque n'entraînent beaucoup de
pesanteur vous donnez à la BPI mission
de
réindustrialiser la France assurer notre
transition énergétique garantir le
respect de l'environnement favoriser
l'activité économique c'est beaucoup
sans doute beaucoup trop je crains que
le principe du couteau suisse à 42
milliards d'euros ne soit un peu
irréaliste l'économiste néerlandais Jan
timbergen avait déjà fait la
démonstration qu'en matière de politique
économique il fallait un outil dédié à
un objectif bien défi or vous nous
présentez un dispositif global tant dans
ses missions que dans sa structure et
dans ses objectif de plus la structure
finale de la holding composant la BPI
n'est pas encore définie la Cour des
comptes avait spécifiquement indiqué
dans son rapport de juillet dernier
relatif au financement de l'économie que
la réunion des compétences d'zo du FSI
et de la branche entreprise de la Caisse
des Dépôts risquerait de générer des
difficultés pratiques car ce sont des
métiers différents monsieur le ministre
je ne peux qu'être surpris que vous
n'ayez pas suivi les recommandations de
la Cour j'ajoute une fois de plus dès
lors je ne peux être qu'inquiet la force
de frappe de 42 milliards sera-t-elle
suffisante au regard des nouvelles
exigences prudentielles que la crise
financière nous a imposé
la BPI devra être soumise à
l'application de normes prudentielles de
deux types selon la nature de son
activité norme prudentielle de la Caisse
des dépôts pour les fonds propres et
celle de balle 3 pour les emprunts
garantis comment s'articulera cette
gestion prudentielle ce n'est pas
vraiment clair c'est même un peu obscur
bal 3 et le
crd4 maintiennent le ratio de
solvabilité à 8 % mais cré des coussins
supplémentaires de fonds propres pour
assurer la continuité de l'activité de
l'entreprise cette pondération des
actifs en fonction des risques signifie
qu'il faudra par conséquent disposer de
fonds propres plus importants pour les
actifs plus risqués le rôle de la BPI se
distingue de celui des banques privées
puisque cette banque publique devra
financer ou garantir le risque des TPE
PME et ETI que les banques privé ne
veulent pas prendre en charge le
financement des PME à long terme le plus
risqué et donc un une des raisons d'être
de la BPI la nouvelle banque publique
d'investissement a pour consigne de se
comporter en investisseur
avisés certes les trois organismes qui
la composent ont une réputation de
compétence mais le spectre du Crédit
Lyonnais
ent toujours nos mémoires enfin monsieur
le ministre je ne peux qu'être dubutatif
quant à la gouvernance du groupe BPI
elle porte le germe de conflit d'intérêt
par la participation des politiques un
élu pouvant être tenté de privilégier un
territoire dont il est issu ou le
représentant et par le risque de se
détourner du financement des projets de
long terme à fort potentiel au profit du
sauvetage d'entreprise que Jean-Pierre
jouillet comparait à des canards boiteux
la définition de la doctrine
d'intervention appartiendra au Conseil
d'Orientation quel sera l'articulation
entre l'to l'État qui doit définir une
stratégie et les régions qui demandent
une part active dans ce processus de
décision quelle sera l'articulation avec
le Commissariat général à
l'investissement avec le futur
Commissariat général à la stratégie et
la prospective cette complexité va
rendre très très difficile sa mise au
point on courre le risque d'une lenteur
administrative qui sera l'antithèse du
but
recherché pour ce qui est des
exploitations la part des PME dans les
exploitations est de 9,8 % alors qu'elle
représente plus de 90 % des entreprises
françaises emploie près de 7 millions de
salariés réalise 34 % du chiffre
d'affair et 42 % de la valeur ajoutée
comment les inciter les aider à exporter
vous avez souligné monsieur le ministre
notre manque d'instrument de soutien à
l'export efficace à l'opposé de nos
voisins allemands et italiens qui
comptent respectivement deux et trois
fois plus de PME que la France celles-ci
ont par ailleurs une forte pulsion
exploortatrice et l'habitude de
travailler en meute aujourd'hui deux
structures fonctionnent pour aider les
entreprises à l'international uifance
établissement public qui uvre à la
promotion de nos entreprises à
l'extérieur et la Coface établissement
privé qui assure le risque vous
envisagez de les intégrer à la BPI dans
un second temps comment allez-vous
fusionner un établissement public et un
établissement privé même si on peut en
espérer la complémentarité sur le
terrain l'écart est grand entre une
promotion publique généraliste et un
établissement privé qui peut avoir
tendance à mettre en avant pour refuser
un dossier les risques du pays ou du
futur client quoi qu'il en soit la
démarche est
ardue vous avez annoncé une réforme
bancaire la création d'une passe d'une
place boursière dédiée au PME ETI en
2013 et la réforme de l'épargne pour
inciter les Français à investir dans
l'économie c'est une idée intéressante
avez-vous néanmoins des précision sur
ces réformes à venir monsieur le
ministre votre projet de loi part d'une
bonne intention mais sucite plus
d'interrogation qui n'apporte de réponse
cela d'autant plus que la fiscalité que
vous venez de mettre en place assèche
les capacités d'investissement des
entreprises et qu'elle est donc tout
sauf incitative
elle ober de plus fortement les marges
parmi les plus faibles je le répète de
l'Union européenne elle ne peut pas non
plus attirer une épargne que vous avez
déjà orienté vers le livra j'ajoute que
dans ce contexte contexte fiscal avec
une tranche à 75 % vous vous mettez à
l'abri des investisseurs
étrangers le projet de loi sur la banque
publique d'investissement n'est pas une
mauvaise initiative et le gichet unique
est une bonne idée mais il connaît trop
d' préparation d'imprécision et
d'incertitude pour que le groupe udi le
vote en l'état par conséquent nous nous
abstiendrons merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Roland d luuard
pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers
collègues le projet de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui crée la banque
publique d'investissement dite BPI
elle été le premier engagement du projet
présidentiel de François Hollande cette
banque sera censée compenser un accès
plus difficile des entrepris auprès
bancaire suite aux nouvelles règles
prudentielles de solvabilité des banques
à ce propos n'en faisant pas plus qu'il
ne faut car si je vois l'exemple
américain ils ont eux différer
l'application de bal 3 sans s'engager
sur un calendrier mais comme toujours en
France quand il y a des normes
européennes on va plus loin et résultat
on Assesse nos
possibilités pour lutter contre ces
problèmes de financement et les manques
de fondes propres la BPI pourra répondre
à une logique proche de celle de
l'investisseur souverain capable
d'entrer au capital de grandes
entreprises porteuses de croissance et
de compétitivité pour l'économie
française en vue de stabiliser leur
actionnariat la nouvelle stratégie de la
BPI s'appuiera sur deux priorités
nationales pour la croissance et la
compétitivité le soutien l'innovation et
l'accompagnement des entreprises à
l'international à travers l'ensemble de
ces outils de financement et
d'investissement la BPI soutiendra les
stratégies nationales de développement
de filières
la BPI offrira un ensemble de services
au travers de guichets uniques régionaux
d'un même réseau de distribution au plus
près des entreprise par ailleurs elle
développera une offre de service et
d'accompagnement des entreprises dans
leur projet de développement la
gouverance nationale et régionale de la
BPI incarne un nouveau partenariat entre
l'État la Caisse des dépôts et les
régions les régions et la BPI créeront
ainsi ensemble des plateformes communes
d'accueil des entre ise pour leurs
besoins de financement en matière de
prêt de garantie et de fonds propres
ainsi pour le gouvernement et sa
majorité trop d'acteurs institutionnels
seraient compétents pour palier les
besoins de financement des entreprises
au eto l'état la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation le fond stratégique
d'investissement et les régions à
travers leur stratégie de développement
économique cependant il me semble que
les données macroéconomiques dont nous
disposons et notamment celle mentionné
dans l'étude d'impact nous montre que le
problème est davantage d'ordre
qualitatif que quantitatif il est en
effet mes chers collègues naïf de croire
que le dispositif actuel conduirait
l'économie française à perdre C points
de croissance des investissements
surtout que le volume des interventions
de l'État ne représente en moyenne
guerre plus de 5 % des marchés des
produits financiers auxquels il prend
part sauf pour les crédits beau
immobiliers ou haosé représente 8 % du
total de ces crédits une question se
pose donc à l'égard du dispositif
français la multiplicité des acteurs
est-elle de nature à aider nos
entreprises cette division du travail
permettant une distinction des rôles une
réelle expertise des acteurs
institutionnels et donc une aide adaptée
à chaque entreprise ou alors peut-on
considérer que cette multiplicité
d'acteurs institutionnels et de nature à
limiter les synergies à empêcher le
partage des connaissances entre
créanciers et actionnaires éventuels
partage indispensable pour offrir l'aide
la plus appropriée à nos
entreprises le gouvernement a pris le
parti du rapprochement des acteurs
institutionnel de l'aide au financement
de l'entreprise cette démarche peut-être
considérée comme positive sur le papier
elle ne change en réalité concrètement
que peu de choses et les ajustements
proposés ne permett pas le redressement
productif que le gouvernement appelle de
ses vœux toute la question mes chers
collègues est de savoir ce qu'apporte la
BPI de plus que ce qui existe déjà ooseo
qui a fait ses preuves pour l'activité
de prêt la CDC entreprise pour
l'activité de financement en fond propre
et la partie PME du du FSI le Syndicat
national de la banque et du crédit dans
un communiqué a déclaré le 17 septembre
dernier je le cite il s'inquiète de
l'extrême précipitation avec laquelle le
projet semble vouloir être mené la
création de la BPI ne peut en aucun cas
se résumer à simplement agglomérer des
compétences existances reconnues et qui
fonctionnent bien au risque d'aboutir à
une nouvelle structure qui ne
fonctionnera pas avec toute l'efficacité
indispensable le projet du gouvernement
ne donne en effet aucune garantie ni sur
la des décisions qui seront prises pour
soutenir les entreprises d'avenir et la
croissance ni sur les moyens financiers
mobilisés souscouvert de nationalisation
de rationalisation pardon des outils
existants il ne faudrait pas aboutir à
la création d'une entité moins efficace
et c'est la crainte que je partage avec
le président Marini qui l'a évoqué tout
à l'heure de plus si le pilotage semble
se simplifier le nombre d'acteurs reste
le même et une certaine division du
travail perdure entre les acteurs en
effet le guichet unique régional ne
comprendra pas que les Services de la de
la BPI c'est-à-dire les anciens services
d'OSO le FSI région gardera ses antennes
comme ubi France et la cofas en outre
les rapports conflictuels peuvent
émerger entre la BPI détenu pour moitié
par la CDC et ses filiales en
particulier aux eo on peut penser que la
CDC aura du mal à contrôler réellement
une filiale dont les fonds propres sont
aussi important que les siens ainsi
l'ensemble du spectre des besoins de
financement de ces entreprises sera
présent dans une même structure
d'accueil c'est bien là le seul point
positif de ce projet de loi il faudra
cependant veiller à ce que ce guichet ne
cristallise pas l'ensemble des attentes
des entrepreneurs car d'autres sectures
continueront d'exister par ailleurs il
existe un risque dans la dans la gestion
de ce dispositif dans la mesure où
celui-ci accord un rôle démesuré aux
exécutifs et élus régionaux qui vont
occuper deux places sur 15 dans le
conseil d'administration de la BPI
participer au comités régionaux
d'orientation chargé de formuler un avis
sur l'exercice des missions de la BPI au
niveau régional et surtout participer au
comité national d'orientation de la BPI
qui sera dirigé par un président de
région nous savons que Bercy avait
imaginé au départ un système centralisé
mais que suite à un lobbyisme intense le
président de l'Association des régions
de France a obtenu l'arbitrage de
Matignon un projet
régionaliste C'est vous qui le dites des
questions se posent n'existe-il pas un
risque de politisation des choix
d'investissement et de conflit
d'intérêts les régions demandent le
pilotage du tissu économique régional
mais dans ce cas est-ce qu'il n'y aura
pas de risque d'utilisation l'outil BPI
à des fins de retournement aux mains de
décideurs politiques avec des comités
régionaux d'orientation présidé par les
présidents des Conseils Régionaux il
existe à mon sens un fort risque de
conflit d'intérêt entre les élus et les
entrepreneurs nous quittons l'hémicycle
du Sénat merci à vous d'avoir suivi
cette séance à suivre le journal de 19h
présenté ce soir par Michel grossior
très bonne soirée à
tous